was it the biography of that new
biography no it was about civility
okay and with that
we are going to uh get going on our
committee hearings for the day welcome
everybody
um
representative majority I don't believe
you've led us in the pledge yet
foreign
good morning once again everybody let's
uh
of the clerk
okay uh Vice Shannon power
present
representative Guthrie yeah
clerk is here representative lasalles
here
representative Kayla
I apologize I just I can't get that name
representwood
present representative Brown
here representative Cahill
here representative State Davis here
representative Tatro
thank you here
uh representative
reporting for Detroit thank you ma'am
representative Gilman here
representative majority here
representative mangaputi
representative Gallagher
here
representative Hicks
I am here
representative Howland here
representative priest here and the
chairman president you
thank you representative McDonald
go ahead and open up the hearing on HB
486 free remove the duties of County
delegations and delegate them to County
Commissioners
welcome
thank you Mr chairman I just want to say
in election law when we start at 10 we
start at 10 but you know
speaks to your leadership pretty close
no um uh good morning everyone my name
is uh Ross Bay represent uh Hillsborough
39 South Manchester Ward's uh six eight
and nine I have about 30 000
constituents
um I I bring that up uh because today I
bring forward a bill to remove the state
representative duties on the county
delegation
um kind of uh where this came out from
was
um a set last year I sat on the
redistricting process
um uh and one of the things that kept
coming up entirely is you can't make
State Rep districts cross county lines
um because we are all on our County
delegation duties
um and that kind of like spurred my
thoughts of like well why are we doing
that
um it's not to change the maps it's like
why are we doing that and when I started
talking to other counties I found out
that there's actually for model Russ
probably won't admit this but there's
actually a lot of people don't even want
to do it there are counties that imprint
during my investigation who shall remain
nameless who actually have to call
around their members to make sure that
enough of us are there so they can have
a quorum to actually vote
um so you know it's one of those deals
of there's three divisions of government
there's local County and state New
Hampshire County government is
notoriously weak compared to how other
states run it um most other states
County government is actually extremely
powerful they do everything schools
um uh full policing that sort of deal as
you guys know in New Hampshire counties
are basically relegated to long-term
care the nursing homes the court systems
uh and the county jail or Sheriff
um so in kind of exploring all of this
it was a one of those intellectual
exercises that I wanted to have of why
are we doing this is it appropriate that
we're doing this and I'll talk about
that in just a second and should we
continue doing it so the reason I ask
the reason I raise the question is is it
appropriate so there's three branches of
government right state
County well it's for federal but we
don't deal with that uh state county and
local
we sit on both uh where state
representatives what we said on both uh
why don't we sit on the local why aren't
we also running the towns
we don't right it would be ludicrous if
we did right nobody would nobody here
would vote for that it's another Duty so
here we have this added Duty for this
branch of government that has very
little power
um and then on top of that we elect
these things called County Commissioners
so when I first kind of floated this
idea to people they said well who would
do the county delegation duties like
well what about the County Commissioners
you know the people we elect to you know
run the county
um so I wanted to have this thought
exercise I I'm not uh I'm not sitting
here saying this must this must vote to
pass this
um there are some long-term concerns so
like let's take koas County they
currently have eight members of their
delegation if the demographic trends of
the state continue they will continue to
lose delegates or state representatives
and it will create a problem for them uh
probably won't create a problem for them
in 2030 but it might start creating a
problem for them in 2040. the trend line
continues they could be down uh in 30
years they could be down to two or three
state reps that are then running the
whole County so it's something that we
don't need to look at it today in terms
of a problem but looking down the road
there will be some issues and I know how
Concord works and I know when you're
doing something like this where it's a
fundamental shift you got to start that
conversation early so people are at
least thinking about it when it does
kind of when it does come time to make
that change so we're not just flying by
the seat of our pants so I'm sure there
will be some awesome questions about
this I hope and I'm more than happy to
are there any questions representative
yokella
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
the question so in um the uh
at the state at the local level there is
um the legislative branches the people
that elect the governing body like the
Selectmen
um and the governing body makes the
budget and then the the legislative body
actually votes for it
how do you see that
separation of powers
um happening at the county level if you
essentially eliminate the legislative
approval process of the budget of the
because you're voting in the the
governing body aka the Commissioners but
then there's they're creating the budget
and there's no kind of check
on the budget that they create yeah so
you can make that argument about state
government right we create a budget that
we pass in the state
um you know the we vote for County
Commissioners let County Commissioners
do it the people vote right you're just
you're the districts are larger right
which is by the way another conversation
that needs to take place if something
like this happens is most of these
Counties have three districts uh and by
the way there's a variety of how long
those terms are
um uh and how they elect those people so
like in Stratford County um there's no
districts they elect three County
Commissioners county-wide if I'm correct
um but in Hillsborough County we have
three districts that are elected
in districts and they serve two-year
terms in Rockingham County there's three
districts they serve four-year terms and
those terms are not all the same so
you'll have a two-year term and two
four-year terms so there needs to be
some uniformity in that
um it's definitely once again this is
the conversation that needs to take
place like would it be appropriate for
there to be you know like in other
states a uh like like a
um a person that's elected county-wide
is acts as a veto or almost like a mayor
of the county if you would
um it's just a question of how long are
we going to be able to keep doing this
how long is specifically kowas County
going to be able to keep doing this
because what's their check there when
they go down to potentially two members
in 30 years what's going to be their
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
have you consulted with kowas County on
this matter I haven't spoken to them
directly um it's just one of those deals
of when exploring this I started to ask
like what happens next right like we
should do
um and I just know that the long-term
trends if the if the trends of the state
continue right where Southern New
Hampshire continues to grow
exponentially faster than Northern New
Hampshire this will become a problem for
them
um it may not be two in 30 years it
could be three and at that point they're
effectively County Commissioners right
because they'll have three districts and
there's three County Commissioners and
co-ops so I haven't spoke with them
directly but it will be as once again
it's not a problem now won't be a
problem in 2030 it probably won't be a
problem in 2040 but looking down the
road it will be a problem if we keep
doing this
representative chair 11.
Mr chair and thank you representative
for taking my question I'm wondering if
during your research you spoke with
people who are legislators who didn't
realize that they were going to have a
delegation obligation for their to their
County as well adding to their workload
yeah um I I did um and thank you for
bringing that up because I missed
something in my opening remarks
um which is a lot of people don't
realize they have to go do this right um
and going back to it there are counties
where their chairmen have to call
through and beg people show up not
begging them to show up like how to vote
right like when we with votes on our
respective sides right we say please
show up and vote you know A or B uh
please show up so they can vote so
um I don't think any I don't think
they'd ever whisper the words in public
right because no one wants to see like I
don't want to do my job but there are a
lot of them that a didn't know they had
to do that job and B don't want to do it
um conversely um there are people
amongst our 400 members who love it uh
I'm not one of them just to be honest
um but there are some that that
absolutely love it uh they like getting
the mileage and some counties do a per
diem reimbursement uh I I kind of look
at it as like every time I come to
Concord I'm losing money
um but I'm also self-employed knowing a
business and so there's there's
definitely a variety of ways to look at
it um I would say anybody who's like
using that line of reasoning to keep
this around should probably
like reconsider um if anybody here is
doing this for the money please tell me
how you're making that work because I'd
love to know
um but in terms of getting more people
to run right we're always talking about
getting trying to get more people
younger people to run
um removing this what I view is kind of
an unnecessary Duty
um could open that up just a little more
I'm not under delusions that if you take
away this that all of a sudden you know
every 20 and 30 year old in the state's
gonna start running for State Rep but
it's just one of those things that you
can take away and make it a little
easier thank you for your answer
for the questions
representative Gallagher
um so about the point about cost
counties
declining population
uh I'm just wondering
uh
why we have to accept that that trend
line is going to continue why can't we
instead Institute policies to encourage
more movement to koas County so that
their population doesn't decline as much
and that they maintain a
similarly size delegation
I think kowas county has been working on
that for as long as co-host county has
been around so
um I I don't believe that's directly
related to this bill
um you know growing the North Country
something I'm sure that they want to do
but it's the reality of the situation is
is if the trend line continues
there's nothing indicating that it's
going to change kovid would have been
the greatest impetus for change where
people could move and work remotely and
they still are having that problem so
it's a this bill is not targeting co-ops
let me be very clear there's just
another piece of the puzzle of this the
point of this is why are state
representatives doing County work when
uh representative majority thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative for
taking the question on on the bill uh
page three lines 24 and 25 and if
someone doesn't have it it's it's with
regard to the oath that we take I I
think I'm understanding then you you
suggested they're striking the line
which says that they shall That We Shall
Serve in that capacity
can I is it correct then to say that
they may if if they would like you're
not are you suggesting that they will
not serve or that they may serve my
intention is that they may not um that
they would not serve would not would not
serve okay um it needs to be one of the
things that does bother me about our
County government across the state in
general is that's not uniform this bill
doesn't fix that problem obviously uh
you know if I was going through I would
mandate that they probably have five
County Commissioner districts uh and
that they'd be elected every two years
like every other branch of government in
the state is a exception of Mayors
um you know one of the features of New
Hampshire uh uh the democratically
elected Republican New Hampshire
um is that we our voters have the
opportunity to change us out every
single two years
um you don't have that opportunity in
County Commissioners but once again
that's not in this bill uh but one of
the things I would like is it to be
uniform uh in the future for all but
that's not a that's a that's a you guys
problem and not not the spill problem
represent excuse me thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr chair
representative Barry do you have an idea
of how long New Hampshire has had the
tradition of having us fulfill this role
my understanding is it's been from the
beginning so once again like I don't I
understand how conquer works and I
understand changing things that have
been the way they always have been it's
like uh you know you get laughed at the
first time you do it but then people
start thinking about it and they're like
oh wait a minute there's there is
representative Holland
so it seems to me the issue you're
saying you're having difficulty
retaining people to do the work or it's
just too challenging because they're
busy rather than advocating your
financial oversight would you instead
just say why don't we allow remote
participation via zoom and make it
easier for the legislator to actually
participate no I still find it
inappropriate on a on a purely divisions
of government level I still find it
inappropriate that people that are
elected for State office are managing
County government once again it will
nobody here would suggest for a minute
that state officers should be
managing municipal government it's the
same those are different divisions right
um so the absurdity of that should be
applied to the absurdity of us running
representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question uh
one of the things that troubles me about
this is Throughout the chapter we talk
about executive committees and uh
subcommittees and if you have a
three-person convention you're dividing
up all that work between the three
people
correct
um so one of the reasons that the bill
has an implementation date of 2031 uh is
uh 2032 excuse me is to find those
problems and fix them because whenever
this changes have this change probably
won't happen this year I'm not
delusional this change will probably
happen in 10 or 20 years so the reason
I've put it into 2032 is to find those
problems and fix them that would give us
I would hope that in nine years we could
you know smoothly launch the ship
seeing none thank you very much
representative Mary thank you guys this
is Lively I enjoyed it
next we will I only have one other pink
cards anybody else who's wishing to
speak make sure you have one uh
um thank you very much I'm
representative Timothy Horrigan from
Stratford County district 10. and I am
I'm a long time member of the Stratford
county executive committee in fact the
county duty is one of my favorite parts
of the job
although sometimes we'll have a
relatively short meeting that goes
smoothly and I'll have actually made
something approaching a living wage for
like going in a meeting for 45 minutes
in our hour at the courthouse and I do
sometimes feel a little bit like that's
probably repugnant to some members of
this body but even I think that's a
little weird but we also have other
County meetings that go on for hours and
hours and you know we're paid
essentially nothing for it um Stratford
County's County government medium-sized
County which probably helps some of the
issues and we've had uh you know fairly
good leadership from both parties and of
course as you know Mr chair you're an
active participant in County government
yourself and that's maybe not been the
mistake in some other counties they had
like a lot of problems in Belknap County
just be partially just because of a
chair and I mean that was who the people
that was who the representative chose
but he was took some questionable uh
questionable positions some of which
proved to be extremely unpopular so that
was and you know so he's not even in the
legislature anymore but um
most of the counties uh the county
commit delegations are fairly stable
body and there's veteran members who
serve for many terms and get to know the
County government
um intimately
um so I I think the county delegation
has a separate role from the County
Commissioners although the lines a
little bit blurred the County
Commissioners are uh are uh you know
they're they're the executive branch of
the County government and the county
delegation the legislative branch and I
think we should keep those uh I think
it's good to keep those separate um
the
the other the other issue is and
representative Barry did of course I
looked at this bill very strange bills
weren't the angle behind it was because
there's uh so part of it is the county
commissions are three members which I
guess has some advantages in terms of
the coherence of the group it's
you're either unanimous or you're two
against one so it was pretty clear like
what the decision is um but that
probably is kind of a small group even
to do with the County Commissioners
already do and then if we're dumping
this much in the workload then that gets
even more unworkable and uh
wouldn't necessarily be a terrible idea
of that five Commissioners or seven and
um I mean if you have a separate bill to
do that I would be supportive of it I
wouldn't support any fundamental changes
with structure County government which I
think is I think is good um
the uh
the revenue also wrote the question of
coax County and I've often wondered
about that I could even imagine it would
be after our time but like when there's
they're only entitled to one member um
and there are a couple of legislative
who might need a constitutional fix one
might be simply
to merge koas County with a neighboring
County probably Grafton would be the
most obvious choice although Grafton
county is already like a pretty large
area as it is and
um you could still keep the county as
you know as a sort of a paper entity for
the purposes of Statistics because you
know subdividing emerging counties Great
Soul college for all kinds of programs
because we have all kinds of data
especially the federal level that is
collected by County but that's
not really an argument in favor of this
bill you have to call us County
delegation gets to be so small that it's
hard to get them to get together to meet
um the social might be just to you know
merged to co-host and Grafton County
delegations and have that group
administer the whole whole area or
Carroll County as the case may be
many other states have done that have
emerged counties like in Massachusetts
effectively most of the counties you
know in Eastern Massachusetts exist only
on existently on paper or at least only
have certain departments done by county
and that can be done here here in New
Hampshire but um I almost think some of
our Hillsborough Rockingham are kind of
unwielding the other direction although
I've sometimes thought about subdividing
the counties in some way but there's no
support for that and that would you know
create more problems than it solved so I
would
basically say you know there may be
issues with some County delegations but
fight from co-ops those aren't
structural problems so it's it's
if things don't go well in the county
it's probably just sort of the function
of uh you know what happens in any
political unit sometimes we do our work
smoothly and as we've done in crap uh
Stratford County throughout the entire
time I've served I'm in my eighth term
and some other counties not so well but
I don't think
eliminating the county delegation
altogether is a good idea a mess for
the issue of municipalities I I just
sort of think Mission College have a
somewhat different legal status in
counties these counties are created by
uh
you know the created by state government
the county delegations legislative
powers are limited a lot of things are
done at the state level so you know it's
within the counties the county can
simply uh if the county and the state of
course you know those are created in
statute by the uh by the law we can
certainly as I said marriage counties or
subdivided counties if we wanted to
um and the legislative districts I'm
this issue came up in uh 2012 for some
reason the 2010 redistricting My Town
manager and I guess his counterpart in
New Market somehow seemed to heard a
rumor that they're gonna they wanted to
merge us into one state legislative
district which
was problematic because we'd never done
it that way and we're crossing county
lines and as far as I can tell
there's nothing in the law that actually
forbid State Rep districts from Crossing
county lines it's just it's a bad idea
and there's a little ambiguity about
which county delegation
the member would would belong to but
presumably he or she could would
probably go to the County's delegation
for their own Community even though some
of their constituents are on the other
side of the County Line and there are
actually some functions where the
Senators have a say appointing certain
officials and actually all the Senators
whose districts going to Stratford
County occasionally are invited to join
the County Convention for certain types
of appointments but
such as the peas trade ports so that's
um
so I just say this is like aside from
possibly increasing the number of County
Commissioners and making it uniform
um this bill is not needed and of course
the chaos with all the different
uh ways of redistricting uh County
Commissioners was created by the
legislature I think
I think strap I think the law for
Stratford county is a way to go on at
Large
a multi-member at large district for the
whole County serving two years I think
that's okay thank you I assume uh by
your discussion that you oppose the bill
oppose yes did I check off the right box
you're at six out uh six minutes and 40
seconds okay well they wrap it up there
yeah I think I said once before the
representative
seeing none thank you all right thank
you thanks thanks
I have no more pink cards is there
anybody who wished to speak
seeing none we will close the public
Mr chair
yes repson
I'm sorry I'm game late but I wanted to
get the blue sheet sign up for this
um representative McDonald we have one
all right we're going to go ahead and
um
when did he get called to I forget
we got subpoenaed for
for police duties yeah he has some other
duties and he's also on the other side
um let's see
my name is representative Stephen bogert
yeah I think that's what he's going to
do and I assume you're here to introduce
representative's behalf thank you go
ahead
good after good morning chairman and
esteemed colleagues my name is uh
Stephen bogert I'm from Belknap County
District Five and uh on behalf of the
sponsor of the bill I've been asked due
to his uh being retained for other
businesses to introduce the bill this
bill is
established a four-year term for the
County Treasurer County Sheriff County
register of deeds and County attorney in
the one Sheriff one County attorney and
one County Treasurer one register of
deed and one of the register of probate
by the voters in each County provided
that at the 2022 state general election
and in each subsequent state general
election May
such offer and record as such officers
in Rockingham County shall be chosen in
the county by the voters for a four-year
term and provided that at the 2024 state
general election and at each subsequent
state general election any such officer
in Belknap County shall be chosen in the
county by the voters for a four-year
term
it's kind of straightforward it seems
every two years these positions are a
nonpartisan position and therefore they
are uh re
as it's currently set up they're
required to run every two years so as
they are elected to their position they
get a reprieve for about six months
maybe a year and then they attention are
being drawn back into getting reelected
um
so therefore it seems like it would make
sense since it's a nonpartisan
non-political type jobs that they
perform that their terms should be every
four years which then the electors have
a choice of keeping them if they're
doing a good job are
picking someone else to do the job
that's basically it
thank you for your testimony uh
representative yukela
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um do you see the election as
um oversight and
and what would the reason for La uh
reducing oversight over
um these positions
um be uh warranted you know reduced even
more than the governor or state reps or
any other position
why do they need less oversight
thank you for your question a lot of
these positions that are are talked
about matter of fact all of them are run
by uh rsas and stuff their duties are
are set forth by state legislation they
don't set up the state legislation they
have to abide by what the legislative
body uh tells them how they should be
able to do their job so therefore they
are not making political decisions that
every two years can change as the people
uh
are in disagreement with the political
views are are not they do not make those
political choices so that oversight is
basically how they're performing to the
legislative duties that are set forth by
the legislature
uh the head representative Manchester
thank you Mr Joe thank you
representative for taking my question
this is exclusively for Sullivan County
belnap sorry Belknap County
and by changing the RSA at the state
level
wouldn't this impact the other counties
and do you how how do you
justify or how can we say Car World just
I do believe that it's already been set
up in another County so that that does
and I think that's that reference of
Sullivan County so it's already been set
forth and and currently
being done
so it would not be set in precedence for
any of the other counties as it may lead
them to make different directions and
how their County elections are ran and
stuff as far as these positions I cannot
say but for the positions here in
Belknap County they would like to see it
further questions
representative Gilman thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative for taking
my question
um
would you consider those positions to be
more of a professional situation because
they all have staff that may be turned
over every two years and the continuity
of the work may change
yes thank you for that question and I
think you you've hit another Point uh
that these are
like you said staff positions and stuff
there staffed by professionals and it
would help and improve the continuity
with their staffs and stuff as they see
the turnover every two years it's hard
to see how office policies and and and
just as soon as you get to learn who is
the head of that department they have a
possibility of being changed out so you
would have that inconsistency going
through whereas if you gave them four
years it would would provide that
continuity
uh between the staff and
the director thank you
representative Hicks thank you Mr
chairman um thank you representative
simple question why four years
it seems like the uh a good term where a
lot of offices have been changed over
across they use that to Senators
themselves use the six years if you look
at the federal it's a six year and if
you look at the House of Representatives
it's two if you look at a lot of your uh
some of the other uh uh States and stuff
four years seems to be the right amount
of time for someone to prove they're
either worthy of doing the job or
they're not
and that way you don't say six years and
then you're tied up
with someone who you really want to get
changed out before
okay
representative Gallagher
um so
um yeah during representative manipuri's
question uh it came up the question of
other counties um
doing similar things and I believe the
county happened with
um previously was actually Rockingham
County where we had a bill not Sullivan
County which were is just on our mind
due to having a lot of other bills about
Sullivan County but anyways
um so with the bill for Rockingham
County's officers to go to four years
last term we actually changed that
to um
apply to All Counties last term in our
committee but then the rest of the house
decided to pull that from the consent
calendar and switch it back to being
just Rockingham County so I'm kind of
wondering why didn't
um Belknap County involved itself in
that conversation
last term when
we had a chance
to include them in the counties that
thank you for your question
unfortunately this is my first term as
from the previous bill they had
mentioned Belknap County had some
challenges that was going through with
their delegation and their
representatives and stuff and uh
the voters had spoke their uh opinion at
The Ballot Box and there were
Replacements put in place for the
representatives uh in Belknap County so
to be quite honest with you I don't
have an answer for you as why they did
not help support
what you that build
in the previous legislation
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question representative so
historically in Belknap County
the offices that would be affected by
this bill are the races for these County
positions typically contested or
uncontested
I do believe out of the four or five
that are being listed uh have not been
contested in years it has been this the
same people in place and the only
position that has really been contested
has been the sheriff's department uh are
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony
um
I've seen several of these bills come
through that's earmarked
or one County or the other
being that
the legislature
um
votes for
everybody else's uh
rules and regulations I guess you'd call
them that why why just
why isn't it being converted to
the way County governments are on
in in one so they're having other other
counties
operate differently than
you know we're passing legislation for
Warren County rather than
thank you for your question
um as I can't speak for the rest of the
State of New Hampshire and how each of
those counties do want to run their
County governments uh
as observing what happened in Rockingham
County where the house
I guess Stripped Away and made it just
for Rockingham County
to re-fight that battle when you're
trying to just achieve something at your
local level uh
seems that it wouldn't pass again
so you would go ahead and and just
shortcom all of that and go straight for
the beef and and do Belknap County and
go from there if other states I mean
other counties wish to join in on it and
stuff
I don't think there would be any uh
opposition to them joining the bill or
anything like that but at this point in
time to uh based on history
Belknap County would be standing alone
uh representative Galaga
um so kind of
um a follow-up to my previous
question
um so he brought up
um
the issues that
um Belknap County faced last term but
um if I remember correctly
um
what wasn't it the case that
the county delegation was trying to
Short Circuit the process and
um like I I didn't think it was an issue
of
um the
County of anything having to do with the
elections like they would they they'd
still be able to
do the same things
they did if the County Commissioners had
I'm not sure what your question is
thank you there's further questions
oh I'm sorry representative lasalles
yes thank you uh I'm over here
dodging the speaker there thanks for
taking my question
um
is there a problem with the text on line
five
just for clarification I believe that's
didn't
shouldn't that be changed
that's not the subject of this bill the
subject of this bill is Belknap wants to
add their name to the list of
four term
kind of like Rockingham did
representative Gallagher well so to kind
of follow up on
um
representative lasalles's question
like wouldn't it be simpler to just
put the
Bell nap directly after rocking him so
it says any such officer in Rockingham
or Belknap counties rather than
inserting an entirely separately
new sentence
for Belknap County
um I can't we
can't we compress things a little bit
here
you could certainly compress things but
I don't think the change in the language
would change the outcome of the bill
whatsoever as it is stated now the
what balnap county is looking for is
just to set it up that way and this
seems to be the simplest way for us to
achieve that goal
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question it's a little bit of
a follow-up question to my previous
question and so for these offices
affected by this bill
with regard to primaries
were they all I assumed that they were
also uncontested in an additional
question is were there any of these
offices in which there was a single
candidate that ran on on both sides
I'll answer that question with the best
of my knowledge I don't
um as far as the
um
the County Attorney the County Treasurer
registry of deeds and the register
probate uh
I don't think they've had and mind you
the best of my knowledge anybody run
against them in a primary and in some
cases I've noticed on the ballot
themselves where they were on both sides
of the ballot because they are
nonpartisan race so it gives them the
opportunity to be there the Sheriff's
Department
they did have Challengers or or whatnot
for that
so
does that answer your question
thank you
thank you very much seeing no more
questions thank you for your testimony
I'm going to turn the hearing over to
representative power to chair I have to
foreign
next I would like to call Sheriff Bill
Wright to the witness stand to provide
testimony
Madam chair and members of the committee
thank you for having me in here today
my name is William Wright I also go by
Bill Wright I've spent 25 years as a law
enforcement officer here in the state of
New Hampshire
I'm currently the sheriff of Belknap
County and I'm in my second term I'm
here today in support of House Bill 357
I've worked for Belknap County Sheriff's
Office since July of 2005. I've been
employed by three separate sheriffs
where each one of those sheriffs had
served multiple terms and had to
as the sheriff of Belknap County I'm
expected to be a full-time employee
I'm expected to answer to my
constituents uh every single day with
literally no days off so
with that
knowing that I was elected into this
office as the sheriff
and knowing that I do answer to these
people
I knew that when I got into this
position I was going to start making
some change within my agency
some of the institutional changes that
the constituents wanted to have happen
I knew that making those cultural
changes within the agency were going to
potentially uh cause an issue with my
current employees that were there that
were hired several sheriffs before me
and I also knew that with a change in
times we had to make these changes
within the agency
knowing that there's a two-year election
cycle for the Sheriff's Office
that that them changes were going to end
up causing a risk for me for potential
uh being ousted at some point
the same goes for like the County
Attorney the register of deeds
and uh the other County offices that are
uh listed in this bill
anytime that we took office we had to
start learning how to do our job in that
specific uh function being the sheriff
for Belknap county has been completely
different than when I was a deputy when
I was a sergeant and when I was being
mentored by the outgoing Sheriff before
I took office it's a completely
different animal it took me a
significant amount of time to learn how
to do my job who
who I report to how that all works uh
the different executive committee with
the delegation the delegation itself as
a whole body uh the commission local
police Chiefs being appointed to
different
um commissions uh the governors like I
currently serve on I'm on the uh
Governor's commission for the Humane
treatment animals
um I'm also on the e911 commission those
take time to learn what to do and how to
do it in a in a two-year term
those days get eaten up pretty fast so
once I started learning how to do this
job well I was already on the campaign
Trail as soon as I got elected because
two years is not a long time
no I know that representative Boger had
said that uh you know we have a six
month to a year reprieve perhaps well I
can tell you as soon as I was elected
sheriff in my first term the process
started all over again for me
um you know we're out there meeting with
our constituents and again learning the
job in in trying to be as effective as
we can
now as changes happen
within the agency
we're faced with making decisions some
decisions were great decisions other
ones not so much so again there's that
learning curve
well 18 months into the job uh that's
when again the I became contested I have
run three campaigns and I've won two of
them and they were all primaries I I
have not had to um
have a second person on the ballot I've
been on the bat on both sides of the
ballot for this position uh twice so far
as a relation to to
um all right correction I was contested
on One race uh during a primary I lost a
primary and I was booted off the off the
ballot the second time uh I had a uh a
Democrat opponent so I I did go into a
general election for that
um and I was successful and then this
last uh race was
um a primary race and then I was put on
the ballot on both sides for the general
two years is just not long enough for us
to do our job effectively
um even though that in the past uh it's
been tradition here in the state to have
two-year election Cycles I believe that
six years the question came up as to why
don't we want longer well six years
might be a little too long uh for us to
get too comfortable in our job is my
opinion so
I think a four-year term gives us the
opportunity to make the changes that we
need to make we learn our job we become
part of the process that that we're
doing similar to me being here
testifying to you now
in that
it just builds a better continuity we're
required to develop policy after every
Sheriff gets done in Chief of Police we
we all have to redevelop our policies we
look at how things are going
um
I can tell you I I went to the National
Sheriff's Institute which was held last
April down in Quantico at the FBI
Academy
and um
I was the only Sheriff out of 25 from
across the country that had a two-year
term
the rest either had four six or eight
year terms
out of that I became kind of the group
study
um about how I was going to Institute
change and that it was going to be
problematic for my agency create uh this
problem with continuity and uh and that
I would be contested they they actually
predicted that I was going to be highly
contested during my next race just
because of the changes and that was
ultimately what I would like to see
um in that I'm most concerned with is a
four-year term here in Belknap County
um just like Rockingham County had done
it last year the committee had decided
to separate all the counties and that it
should be up to those individual
counties to come forward and ask to be a
move to a different term and I'm asking
for this to be found ought to pass
um I'd like to recognize Representatives
Davis
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
um as my colleague stated a few minutes
ago
after previous testimony the the bill
for Rockingham County came before this
committee
uh we as a matter of custom we tend to
not look favorably on bills that affect
specific counties or specific entities
because it raises matters of fairness
for other counties in the entire state
uh and consequently for the people who
vote for those positions in decisions in
the entire State
um the legislature in its wisdom
um decided that that was not a good
approach but now here we are back again
trying to solve what is being stated to
us as an issue of it's tough to learn
your job in two years and then campaign
again I get that
um but that is the way it is why Belknap
County and not Sullivan County or
Grafton County you know what can you
speak to the fairness of requesting this
for your position and your colleagues
positions but not other similar
positions Statewide
yes I was actually uh with the sheriff's
Association at the time when when the
previous Bill uh was put forward in that
Rockingham County was uh successful on
that
and part of that reasoning was it became
it came before this committee here
um it started out as a Rockingham County
Bill and then uh all the other counties
had jumped on board with it and it got
presented
at
this committee was in favor at that time
of of
ought to pass the problem is is that
once it went to the
um I believe it went to the Senate and
the senate had weighed in on it and
there was a problem with one of the
counties that there was some distension
or opposition to to that specific County
not wanting to move forward with with
that as a relation to that
um
As Time moved on there was no consensus
that was going to be reached so it was
determined that they were going to
separate uh all the other counties out
of it because again we were the
afterthought
um to it originally so they returned the
language back to the original bill that
was submitted and that was the bill that
so if to answer your question about uh
do we think it's fair or what have you
uh all the sheriffs across this state
were in favor of being on this original
Bill to have the terms move to four
years there was not a single Sheriff
that was against that now I only speak
on behalf of the sheriffs because those
are the folks that I predominantly
associate with
um in this
manner
representative mangaputi
thank you madam chair thank you sheriff
for taking my question I have two-part
question one is you made a mention about
being
a democrat or a republican you didn't
mention Republican by name but you said
you had a democratic opponent earlier we
heard this is a non-partisan position so
why did that question of whether you're
a democrat or a republican rise
the second part is if all sheriffs all
County Sheriffs think this is a good one
how come it's still just Rockingham I
mean Belknap County Why didn't
you put that in as all counties
okay thank you for the question
so let me let me answer the second one
first so ultimately the representatives
that are in my County decided to put
forward this bill because they followed
the recommendation of what happened in
in the committee last time around where
the bill got separated in that it was it
was stated to have each County
individually uh make a presentation so
the representatives that are in my
County agreed that this would be a good
idea for us to
um to put it in as it's a legislative
session now so that's why you see
Belknap County and not the other
counties because we've already been down
that road of trying to get everybody
Incorporated and that did not make it
through so now we're doing what
Rockingham did and asking individual
the second part of the question or the
first one you you talked about the
ballot the separation of the ballot so
this is a non-partisan uh position I
don't I honestly don't care what's next
to the last name that they have when I'm
doing my police services but the state
law requires us to run on the ballot uh
in a primary so at that point we have to
make a decision where we sit in our
political realm if you will
so
um
so saying that I I did not get primary
because there were specific questions
about primaries and all that uh during
previous testimony uh I wanted to signal
that I was not primary during one of my
campaigns but I was challenged during
the uh General
any other questions will witness
representative yokella
thank you thank you for uh taking the
question
um going back to what I previously uh
questioned the previous person about uh
kind of oversight by the electorate
um
if uh if the job is being done
adequately or appropriately
um
there may not be a frequent turnover but
in the cases where the job is not being
performed adequately
why do you believe that the that the
the county position should be filled for
four years in an adequate in an
unadequate position in a unadequate
situation when we have the current
opportunity to change that over in two
years if if it's not being handled
appropriately or maybe they're
instituting policies that are not
so in the area of
the Sheriff's Office
when I took office I started institution
instituting cultural change it's
something that previous sheriffs did not
do so we were operating based on 30
years ago the way that it ran because of
fear of
issues that might arise with with
employees or with the union or whatever
that's inside uh the operations of our
agency
I was a person that when I campaigned
originally
I said I was going to make the changes
that were that were necessary to bring
us up to today's date in time uh in what
I have been trained in
to be better
as soon as I started implementing those
changes that's when
we started seeing the disruption and if
you will the employment
so in two years anybody can pretty much
fake it first for 18 months and then
they can go and support another
candidate and hide behind that sign and
say anything that goes forward now is a
retaliatory issue which creates a
situation that
um is not necessarily favorable to our
constituents or the or the county itself
so a four-year term you cannot you those
who uh were on my staff and perhaps I
maybe turned my staff over when I first
came into office
choose my own number two uh my number
threes and so on and so forth
I have four years to implement my
changes four years to prove to the
constituents uh in those that I report
to you that the changes were made that
were they were effective and that my
leadership was effective
a two-year term does not allow that
because again
um if I wanted to keep this the office
status quo then I could probably not
have had any disruption at all
but I was a person of change I was a
person of progress so making that
progress creates that disruption
um and I can tell you that having to uh
fight the second term for a second term
uh was very distracting to the internal
operations of the agency
even though that I'm doing my stuff
outside and away from the office it
still detracts from this job itself a
four-year term will show a demonstrated
ability in in actual changes cultural
changes are being made so I was not
afraid to make those changes and uh and
there's other sheriffs that are in the
foreign
thank you madam chair and thank you
sheriff for taking my question
um I'm not sure this one can be answered
but if a bad guy is going to trial
can you give me an average for how long
it takes for that whole process from the
time that bad guy for something really
bad has been arrested to the time that
that case has been fully adjudicated
takes
sure because the Sheriff's Office deals
with warrants and uh we see the the
transition of the cases I could tell you
you know just yesterday we had it we
cleared an arrest warrant that was a
case was over two years old
and that seems to be kind of a
traditional uh process though if you add
situations like the last pandemic where
the courts were closed for almost an
entire year
you start you know everything starts
stacking up and everything gets kind of
pushed uh to the back burner and uh due
process is slowed so you can say that
it's it's at least two years as a normal
uh you know year and a half two years
sometimes even longer for these cases to
yeah
representative Cahill
kind of a follow-up to that question
if that occurs and you're no longer
Sheriff can you still get called back to
testify in that case
sure if it's a case that I've had
involvement in I can be subpoenaed at
any point I would come in as a person a
civilian being served
um you know a subpoena to go in and
representative
thank you Mr chair
um one more question in terms of
process that it takes for a sheriff's
County
um
typical cases that sheriff department in
accounting handles what's the length of
processing the kind of cases that you
get as at the sheriff's level
that can vary I mean we because we're
multi-jurisdictional we have the ability
to investigate crimes that occur in
multi-jurisdictions
so depending on the case they they could
go I mean you know I had a case that was
solved within an hour uh yesterday and
then uh you know one of my detectors
worked on and then we've had other cases
that we've been working on for three
years
um you know we like our agency has been
tied tied into uh investigating some of
the uh
the uh sexual abuse cases from years ago
uh from some different communities in in
those sometimes take a significant
amount of time so the cases can last a
significant amount of time it all
depends on
Witnesses and evidence and whatever we
can get to bring it to closure
follow-up Mr chair
go ahead thank you Mr chair so if and
it's a multi-jured restriction in
different towns and cities are involved
so
is it more complicated longer if it has
you have to work with the local police
departments for example if it's a
Hillsborough County but you know then
have to work with the Nashua Police
Department so would that be longer if
you have to collaborate with other
people
at the police department
it can take some time but again we so as
a sheriff's office we've always worked
very well with other jurisdictions
especially those that are contained
within our own jurisdiction so
um the timeliness is normally you know
again we want to turn over cases and get
them cleared as quick as possible uh
that's for the victims and and for the
court prosecutions and all that so
um
we don't really have those problems what
comes into a problem is the the
technicalities of the cases computer
crimes we're waiting for you know we got
a sense subpoena as a search warrant
south of California to get uh different
documentation and things from these uh
internet companies that can take some
time
um different Court processes that happen
sometimes delay the cases themselves so
we don't really have too much delay when
it comes to Cooperative efforts with
local PDS
thank you
seeing no more questions thank you very
I have one final pink card uh Kate
Horgan
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Kade Horgan I
represent the New Hampshire Association
of counties
um and yes we heard the legislature loud
and clear last year it was said in the
floor debate if you want this change for
your counties make sure to get the
support of your delegation and bring the
bill in just for your county that is
what Belknap has done they have the
support of their delegation these are
administrative positions and as the
sheriff pointed out making changes often
takes more than two years especially in
your registered Deeds office who are if
they have not already they are in the
process of putting you all of your Deeds
that you are responsible for online so
that the public can access them that is
not something that can be done in two
years it is a multi-year project I'm
happy to take any questions but everyone
else has covered all of the other points
I wanted to make and I'll conclude my
representative uh yokella
thank you and I'll I'll try and ask
um my question again and see if if
um
you have a different and can address it
a different way so every time I ask
about the oversight by the electorate
people are responding about how you know
their job is complicated or it would be
easier for their job but I'm trying to
um to assess the the value of of the
actual legislative
body that elects the people and being
able to oversize oversee
these changes that are being implemented
if if it's going according to plan they
might re-elect them but if they don't
why shouldn't the uh the people be able
to say this is not the path that we need
to go down I want to vote you out of
office why is that not appropriate thank
you for the question representative
ukella I would say it is not
reducing oversight they still have to
run they still have to get elected we're
just increasing the amount of time that
they have in the office and the voters
in Rockingham County who went through
this the last time there were no changes
in Sheriff Deeds register of probate
County attorney there were no changes
they already think that their people are
on the right path and I believe it was
brought up earlier the turnover in these
positions is very low so I don't think
it would change the oversight because
foreign
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so
um this bill is sponsored by indiv
legislators from Belknap County and in
your testimony you made the comment that
Belknap county has support from their
delegation could you expound on that and
clarify what exactly do you mean by that
statement it is my understanding and I
would defer to the sponsor to confirm
this but that their delegation discussed
this bill and supports this bill but I
would defer to the representative from
thank you
so you know no more questions I have one
quick one for you for the benefit of
those of us who were not on this
committee last year could you give an
executive description or a version of
why the bill last year
uh to make all counties for this four
years why did that fail so this bill was
changed by the committee to impact All
Counties it went to the house floor and
it was actually on the consent calendar
it was I believe a unanimous or nearly
unanimous vote out of this committee
uh it was pulled from the consent
calendar and uh the testimony or the
floor debate specifically said not every
delegation got to weigh in on this bill
so therefore we want to make sure each
delegation has the opportunity to weigh
in on that bill I believe it was
specifically said if Rockingham wants to
do this and they have their delegation
support then yes let's pass that but
every other delegation needs the
opportunity to weigh in to see if that
makes sense for their County
sure uh representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so it was on the floor that
it changed but as a committee it was
unanimous so bringing you the bill is
being brought to the committee it was
very clear last time when we voted on
that to do a uniform across the counties
having said that having shown the action
why this time just one county is my
question thank you for the question it
was stated to us very clearly
representative that we if we were going
to bring this back it needed to be done
thank you
representative Gallagher
um so
um when you say it was stated to us
could you specify who specifically
stated that
thank you representative it was said in
the floor debate
okay see no more questions thank you
very much thank you Ms Horgan um could
we have
uh I guess representative Boger could
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking the question
so I'm going to ask this same question I
just asked the last witness and that
pertains to the comment that the
delegation
um supports this this bill
she the the previous witness stated that
she it was our understanding that the
delegation discussed the this bill in
particular could you confirm and um
explain if the delegation did discuss
this and if any consensus was was
achieved
yes thank you for the question the bill
itself did not officially come up before
the delegation at a delegation meeting
it had been discussed uh individually
and as you can note that four of the
foreign
thank you
Representatives Davis I said one more go
ahead quickly please thank you Mr chair
were any members of the county
okay thank you very much for your
testimony sing no more uh I don't have
any more pink cards on this
seeing no more questions we'll close the
on that last one blue sheet we had one
okay we're going to open up the hearing
now on HP 51 representative boam you are
up
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
municipal County
committee the record I am Ralph boam
Hillsboro district 14 town of Litchfield
I have a former Selectmen School Board
budget committee and 15 years here
and I understand the probably Amendment
coming on this which probably I look
forward I went around and around with
legislative services on this language
and I just gave up with him anyway
current law states that state funds
cannot be used to lobby for legislation
in 2006 when I was on Election law
commission committee we amended RSA 15-5
to state that the towns and school
districts must keep funds for lobbying
agencies and several accounts that do
not use State funds I doubt that anyone
is doing this
also lobbying agencies such as a
municipal Association and a School Board
Association do not represent the
taxpayer and they actually Lobby against
the taxpayer
lobbying for the town and School Board
Administrations
a good example of this at the municipal
Association lobbied against the bill
that would have made it clear that the
default budget was never supposed to be
higher than the proposed operating
budget this house
this Committee in the house passed us
last year but the municipal Association
lobbied successfully in the Senate to
kill the bill like I said the and the
taxpayer is paying these associations
this bill will make it transparent to
the taxpayer that they are funding
lobbying for their town and School
District administration with local funds
only let's have some transparency and
let the people decide thank you
thank you representative do we have
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and um thank you
representative for taking my question
so when I look at the the architecture
of this bill in in the language
I see that your um
referencing RSA 15 colon 5 and also
um
you're putting in a new section
so my question is is
why did you choose to
um make these amendments to to do what
you wanted to do in in this bill and and
do it within those sections of Statute
and not
budget preparation
and that would be RSA 32 colon 5.
because
the 15-5 specifically is there for
lobbying purposes can't you not use
State funds for lobbying for example a a
state agency cannot come in and Lobby
for a bill
um about using State money so that's why
I put in that bill and I remember in the
testimony in 2006 when I was on Election
law the Pacific reason for putting in
for the separate accounts for Town and
School District can make but
specifically for taking care of the
municipal Association and the School
Board Association because people had
problems with it then also so again it's
the school districts and towns get State
money we go and make sure that the
people know for any lobbyists including
a city might hire their own lobbyists
that only local money can be used so
that's why I use 15.5 because that's
where the current law is about State
money for lobbying
but if you
think it could be somewhere else I mean
yeah
for the questions representative your
fella
thank you uh thank you for taking the
question
um
why
is why did you make it just a one-time
vote and and uh
of the town to to Grant lobbyists
lobbying
um
well the money well more make it
transparent but it could be maybe make
it put it in the budget staying it's got
to be all the time I would be full in
favor of that also you know but uh you
know if you want to change the law doing
that I'll be
that's okay with me if I just want to
also to make it transparent to you no
local fund only your tax dollars is
going for this agency
representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question representative and it
may be a follow-up to representative
ukulla's question I I understand that
with this language there would have to
be a warrant article maybe inclusive of
all the agencies or maybe separate
Warren articles for each agency it seems
that that could be that there could be
discussion but my question is really the
budget then would also have to include
the funding for each one of those
lobbying efforts and would these then if
the budget is approved but the warrant
article fails that means then the
funding fails correct correct and and
the budget has all those line items in
the budget for funding your Municipal
Association what not but I only see one
one article for foot lobbying purposes I
mean the school districts would have one
the municipality in the town will have
one I mean if the city like Nashville
wants to hire their own Lobby that's
done in the city government not in town
so yeah there's only going to be maybe
one extra but then like representing
Powell said maybe we should be let's put
in law and 32 column five I mean that
would be okay with me also like
representative Gallagher
so let's say this goes into effect and
um
some
some towns
vote to approve warrant articles to
um fund these associations and then
other towns don't do so so
if that happens with the associations
then
are be supposed to be
um representing
the interests of all towns are just the
ones that have paid decided to
um pay pay them
pretty much just the ones that pay them
for the sample I know in the uh in in
both agencies not all towns or cities
contribute and the school district there
are a number of school districts that do
not
contribute to the School Board
Association so I mean so what the point
is also if some people say some towns a
lot of towns say no then maybe even
Municipal Association School District
School Board Association will change
their policies
but that's one way of looking at it but
yeah I mean only they only represent
those municipalities that contribute to
their budget
representative status
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question could you define for
me lobbyist
well in this and this thing is lobbying
in the legislature
for a particular bill in other words I'm
for this bill I'm you know for what we
have the people but the orange tags
doing they are lobbying state agencies
cannot Lobby because they get State
money so for example I'm I was on the
education for years and was always a
point when we asked the the doe
Department of Education what do you
think about this bill their answer was
always we can't say that
that'd be lobbying so that's lobbying
and misassociation I guess you don't
have really any I don't know state
agencies that can come and Lobby I mean
maybe the school board associate I mean
the municipal Association but they're
paid lobbyists and that's what I'm
talking paid lobbyists people that are
although
thank you Mr chair would you consider a
if I mean
yeah if they're pushing a particular
Bill if they're answering questions no
but if they're actually pushing a bill
then yeah they're lobbying
and who decides whether they're
answering the questions yes thank you
thank you Mr chair I apologize
who decides whether the person in front
of you is answering a question or
lobbying I mean you all I mean the point
is it's I mean like we we've I've been
on other sitting and in other committees
and I know some committees are kind of
lacks on letting their agencies really
lobby but I mean that's that's an issue
and in some cases but really State money
cannot be used for lobbying for obvious
purposes you know I mean we're paying
the Commissioners and different
department heads
to do their job and their job is what we
decide as legislation not what they are
pushing they can answer questions but
they can't really shouldn't be really
pushing
for a bill
representative Holland
so this is kind of a follow-up I'm sorry
I hope that works uh on representative
Davis's question so would you consider
like training on right to know or
training on hot the duties of a school
board member or training on how to do
Municipal work is that lobbying no
that's that's
let's say doing what they're being paid
for by the school district and the
municipal for that training I mean
they're not coming here lobbying is
coming here
okay and saying we need this bill passed
so we can do this that's the lobbying by
doing the job that the school districts
and misflow stations is being paying for
them to do that's not representative
Elward
thank you Mr chairman and thank you rep
for your testimony today is it not true
that a lobbyist must be registered uh
and that they advocate for a fee
yes thank you and in first case in this
Association and School Board station are
paid lobbyists correct thank you
representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
I'm over here I'm sorry okay
um you have mentioned several times that
lobbyists are always or it seems to me
always lobbying for a bill
uh what if a town
doesn't like a bill
who can come and Lobby against that bill
well when I was on the school board I
I've come here
when I was in the legislature also and
and talked on a bill
you know but
I'm I wasn't paid to be
I'm not paid to be a lobbyist but I was
paying for what my my school board
wanted me to talk about or as a private
citizen
I mean that's no problem I'm not don't
have an orange tag I mean so I mean a
lot of cases I've had the private
citizen I've come
to to speak against or for a bill
representative color
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
so
lobbyists are defined and who is
registered and what they can and cannot
do
um in RSA 15 colon 1.
and so
would would you be encouraging the
representatives to refer back to that
section or of law for what is a lobbyist
or what is not or or should we be taking
is basically giving what the rest of 15
is I mean so 15 5 is what what was the
section that specifically says State
funds cannot be used
I mean that's
for lobbying and that's my my point
representative bench putty thank you Mr
tooth thank you representative for
taking my question my question is it's a
very
distinction between lobbyists and
lobbying for a bill we have had
departments come and testify against or
for a bill would you consider that yes
as a lobbying debt breaking the law as
far as I can read 15 colon one through
five there they are there being paid by
the state
to do a job
and if they come here in law before
against the bill in their position
that is against the law
now I have no problem with somebody
coming and and has a private citizen for
a bill but by lobbying for the
Department
no that's why I said in the Department
of Education whenever we've asked their
attorney or other members of the doe on
on what they think about a bill they
always say we can't say you make the
laws and we abide by them
follow-up Mr follow up thank you but as
a committee members we do ask for input
from specific departments that comes to
my mind right now is the Secretary of
States where we needed a response and
they had to say whether the support or
not or how would it impact would that be
considered lobbying I've I've run it
across that in the election law and I
think some of the comments a very
borderline on being
being lobbying and they should say you
know they should the question to be
asked what do you think I mean but they
representative Davis
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
I'm listening to your testimony and I'm
I'm I want to ask you again
who draws the line between what is
considered
by you and other supporters of this bill
as lobbying for or against a bill
and who is exercising their right of
free speech it seems to me that anyone
anyone who has anything to do with a
formal State body
who is arguing for or against a piece of
legislation or a policy would be
considered a lobbyist
under the terms of this well the point
is like I mean
RSA 15 I think makes it pretty clear if
you're gaining State money you cannot
Lobby that that's pretty clear I mean
um
so like if I'm getting if I'm getting a
salary from the state
I I shouldn't be loud and I don't think
yeah and that's for us as legislators to
I think we're going to wrap this up this
right individual up really quick uh
we're going to uh represent a brown
quickly please
thank you Mr chairman just a quick
question so if we asked uh some from the
Eternal generals officer Department of
Education
what difficulties would this cause or is
this uh legal or what would be involved
with implementing this
that's okay I think if you ask like if
it's legal on and they can existing law
or maybe State no the existing law says
you can't do that then that that's fine
but they can't be pushing for anything
just a quick follow-up quickly
representative so so as long as they
don't give their opinion they're not
lobbying
thank you asking questions that's fine
okay thank you thank you for your
testimony we are going to move on we are
getting behind uh gonna call nature
thank you Mr chair and H Grace for the
municipal Association we are opposed to
this bill
um the committee had a number of good
questions
um and I do want to start out by saying
that uh I have a couple handouts for you
uh we have a letter and I am also
handing a letter on behalf of Lori Radke
the Town Administrator for Hollis who
couldn't make it today but wish to
provide the the committee with some
information
foreign
so um
a number of committee members had uh
questions about who draws the line
between
um free speech and lobbying and how
exactly this relates to
state agencies and the kind of
information they provide as some do come
in and uh support or oppose legislation
um and I agree that this is an
incredibly difficult line to draw as
you'll hear from me later today there
are a number of bills coming before you
today that we do not have a position on
but just wish to provide some technical
information on I'm cautious so I count
that as lobbying time but I understand
there's a difference of opinion there
um there are three main points I want to
make uh today before you
um so I want to draw your attention to
lines seven and eight where it refers to
each agency
um and that towns and and essentially
this seems to state that towns can't use
one worn article to list all
organizations that would lobby with
money received
and it's really unclear what the scope
of this is going to be
um being cautious I'd say that this is
going to end up cluttering the warrant
you could easily have a dozen or more
worn articles because you're talking
about building officials Public Works
Association Health officer Association
assessors Etc
um there are a ton of local I guess I
should say small organizations that
work with local officials in different
capacities and it's unclear where the
cutoff is for lobbying
um it's not really clear whether it's
supposed to be inclusive of all those
organizations or other ones and just to
illustrate uh one RSA that you can look
up
where um just to show you how small an
amount of money we're talking about here
RSA 31 colon 8 which relates to the
assessors and town clerks their
Association is 20 bucks a year
um so you're having a separate one
article for 20 bucks
um there is a bill Senate Bill 88 that
might change that
um but it seems the intent here is to
Target dues and membership organizations
which offer more than just lobbying
services and that's my my second Point
here which is that
um really these organizations are the
way that Municipal officials
particularly in specialized areas
receive the training education they need
to do their jobs
I certainly am not a town clerk I don't
know all the aspects of what they do I'm
not an assessor I don't know what they
do I'm not a building official and
certainly I try as much as I can to help
out with them but when you're talking
about you know the intricate nature of
the building code and amendments the
building code potential amendments the
ramifications
that's not something that you know I
would have a specialty and that's
something that somebody who's familiar
with that has a specialty and that's why
they have these organizations so they
provide the specialized Education and
Training
um and they often provide access to
state and federal resources that would
not otherwise be accessible to
to those officials so for example every
year I get to go over to the Wastewater
manager school at DES and provide
information to people training to become
Wastewater managers so that you can all
have public sewer systems and provide
them information about the right to know
law because as local officials they have
to know what that is
understand what it is and if they get a
night a right to no law request
understand how to respond to it
appropriately
and oftentimes the training and training
and educational resources provided by
these special organizations are not
provided by any other entity
so you know for nhma's sake we've
inherited some trainings that aren't put
on by state agencies anymore we put on
Specialized trainings for land use
officials who put on Specialized
trainings for
um Trustees of trust funds for Cemetery
trustees
um for Library trustees some of that
used to be done by the state it's not
anymore
some of some training is done in
conjunction with the state and some we
just do entirely separately I counted it
up and I don't remember exactly the
number but when I introduced myself to
the committee a few weeks ago I said it
was somewhere around 80 I think
trainings we did
last year with our basically four staff
members doing those
um so that's a lot more than just here
because we do that we do provide legal
advice to cities and towns that call
um and obviously I come here and talk to
all of you about legislation
and currently the cost to be a uh a
member of any of these organizations is
included in the budget it's typically
under a line called do's and
subscriptions or dues and memberships uh
it depends on your specific Town um how
you're going to name that but if you do
have a sub account
information the municipal budget law
under 32 colon 5 Roman one does require
that that information be available for
public inspection at the budget hearing
and there's a definition of what a
sub-account means under 32 colon 3. so
voters can already see what they're
looking what money is going out of the
town they can already determine
a town meeting where they think it's
appropriate for their towns to be
members of their organizations
um or you know officials to be members
of those organizations
and they can determine whether to
authorize or remove that expenditure um
they you know if it's something that the
governing body put in if you're an SP2
Town deliberative session certainly make
that motion to remove that line and
prevent that expenditure from occurring
or on the floor of a town meeting a
traditional town meeting and of course
you could have a separate War article
that would trigger no means no so you
could put in a warn article that says
you know don't fund whatever the
organization is and that has certainly
happened
um in the past there have been
um municipalities that have decided for
example not to be members of nhma
Merrimack is one of those Salem is one
of those they weren't members for a
while
um I'm happy to take any questions the
committee has
thank you any questions uh
representative ukella thank you thank
you for taking the question
you seem to be
um
implying that
um the trainings and the lobbies
lobbying efforts go hand in hand is
there any reason that these efforts
couldn't be split out and paid for
separately and not
um not uh
tied together in in the way that you're
describing
so
I guess that goes
that goes back to the question of you
know what was the role of people who
come here
um and in part to provide information
um state agencies certainly required to
to do that but they may have some sort
of best practice they want to share or
some sort of policy that they think
would be easier to implement and
therefore would have a position on it
that's often developed through the
course of those trainings because you
know when you get a bunch of people
together in a room who have a specialty
they
can talk about whatever the issue is and
run through different scenarios and what
might be possible what might not be
possible and that's that's uh frequently
what happens uh especially with
um the really specialized organizations
um and I do want to point something else
out which is that
I understand the intent is to prevent
lobbying efforts but from
local officials really but
um
towns also and and local officials
structure this differently so I think
one of the organizations you will not
see sign in support sign in opposition
unless I've I've not done my homework
correctly is the fire chiefs Association
and that's because they don't take money
directly from the town
um they end up each individual chief
decides to join that organization or not
and they have a lobbyist here that's uh
um I don't believe you're answering his
questions anymore
representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Grace for taking my question
um the lobbying effort we we're talking
about here seems to be I'm going to use
the word reactive
um that the lobbying would be in
response to something
um but the lobbying that uh the the
efforts from nhma are a response to a
process can you explain that process and
how it could be affected by this bill
absolutely so uh every election year
um we at nhma ask local officials to
volunteer to be part of one of three
committees that looks at what our
existing policies are for what we
advocate for at the legislature
these committees uh typically end up
being between 15 and 20 people sign up
and usually between 12 and 15 actually
show up so they're not big committees
they they look at what our policies are
they make suggestions about how to
change those those suggestions then get
compiled mailed out to all of our all of
our members which is currently all 234
cities and towns and those members get a
chance to look at them in advance
decide if they support them if they
don't support them if they want any
changes and we have a policy conference
that's I would say and now I guess to
what happens uh on the the floor of the
house and so we try to get as many uh of
the cities and towns together who are
our members and they decide what they
want us to come advocate for so you know
this year we saw some changes with what
we do for housing in response to the
fact that there doesn't seem to be
enough housing and so we were told to go
advocate for
um four bills that would allow more
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so this is a
follow-up to the representatives
question that you um just answered so
you explained that you have this process
with committees that local locally
elected officials or appointed officials
are part of these committees in a board
of directors perhaps to to get
information with regards to New
Hampshire Municipal associations
positions and what you're going to
provide input with regard to legislation
and and in committee so my question is
these um local local officials do they
in turn turn to the taxpayer and and get
information from the taxpayer in terms
of what type of input is brought forward
with regards to the process that you
explained
so there's no like legislative body vote
at the local level they would typically
it would be the governing body so the
select board or the city council that
would that would weigh in on these
obviously they are always concerned
about what their property tax rate is so
that is something that
undoubtedly comes into consideration
when they tell us what we should
thank you
um we we really need to get a move on if
it's if it's a question that has not
been asked and answered representative
Gilman
go ahead
um thank you for taking my question
um just just to follow up on
representative Powers thing uh if I'm us
it's anecdotal so if I'm not elected as
a select board member and also a state
representative and my slip board decides
uh to vote on whether to support or
oppose a bill
if I bring that decision back to the
possible
I will say that there is
um the AG's office and Secretary of
State's office did produce a guidance
document a few years ago about what it
means to be a lobbyist I'm not entirely
sure that I understand that guidance
document so I always try to be as
conservative as possible that's fine
representative Elwood last uh question
for rep Mr Grace thank you Mr chairman
Mr Grace thank you for taking my
question is it not true that nhma
provides advisory only legal advice to
towns and if so can that advice be used
adversely against any taxpayer
so
nhma provides General legal advice so if
you had a you know you had a question
about
how the right to know law works or
something you could as a local official
you could call and we would provide you
that advice
um generally we get called in response
to specific questions that local
officials have it may be the case that
it's in response to a citizen inquiry
and we have some municipalities that
just call us in response to that some
don't whether they release that
information to the public or not is is
not up to us and whether there's sort of
uh subsidiary effects they go to Town
Council and talk to them about the
advice we have is is not up to us either
because each town has their own their
own lawyer that would go to court for
them we don't go to court for towns okay
thank you yep
thank you Mr Grace
um we have four more thank you
individuals who wish to testify I'm
going to ask and uh I'm going to ask by
chairman power to use their stopwatch
here most of you have all said you need
two or three minutes we're going to hold
you to less than three minutes if it's
already been said don't repeat it if
it's uh if you get questions I'd ask you
to respond in your questions briefly and
concisely and specifically we're running
behind we need to get caught up here so
foreign
hi my name is Eric power I am a resident
of Brookline New Hampshire I'm here
representing the sdga organization which
is the school district governance
Association of New Hampshire
um just for backgrounds I've served on a
Cooperative School Board I've headed DPW
study committee budget.com Bud com study
committee and I'm currently on the
planning board in Brookline
and I've had a lot of good interactions
with the uh
New Hampshire Municipal Association and
the School Board Association from those
roles
but I realized that they provide they do
provide a lot of good services but they
also do lobbying and there's a
distinction there and what they're doing
this year I've actually put petitions
into two of our school districts or
Hollis Brookline Co-op and our Brookline
School District to try to zero out that
line item I've received um
a lot of resistance from that saying
whether deciding whether that's legal or
not so we're going to see where that
goes that's in this year's town meeting
um I've also worked a lot in the defense
industry on government contracts
whenever there's money being used for
lobbying it always has to be separated
out
it's considered what they call a
non-allowable cost
that's that's important because we just
can't use the money and mix it together
I also serve in the Air Force for 30
years in the National Guard and I also
joined the National Guard Association
but I paid the dues myself I decided
they do lobbying but it was my money it
wasn't being paid by the Air Force
so that's an important piece
um I believe that the solution to this
would be to put a uh this the intent of
this bill in RSA 32-5
and it would clearly state that an
operating budget for a municipality
which would also include is School
District cannot allow any uh money
that's lobbying under RSA 15 1.
but if the governing body with the
school board or the select board decided
that they wanted to have these services
for lobbying from an organization and it
could be multiple organizations it would
have to be in a special Warren article
so it would have to be pulled out of the
budget so there would be an operating
budget and if they chose if they decided
to do have lobbying money and they could
put all the organizations that the town
has or all the organizations the school
district has in one article they could
they could do that and let the voters
decide if they want those services for
lobbying
I think that would be a very clean way
to do it
this would require however for nhma and
School Board Association and others to
tell the towns and school districts
here's the money we use for services and
here's the money that we're using for
lobbying which is not a bad thing to do
and I'd also say just from my own
experience on the various roles that
I've had over the years and also the
position of the school district
governance Association that very
frequently the lobbyists are going
against the wills of the parents and the
taxpayers and they're more for the
administration of the school and the the
town employees and town administrators
so I think it's important for the for
the taxpayers to be able to have this a
separate Warren article and I'd be glad
to take any questions thank you thank
you for your testimony are the questions
representative troll Evan
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
power coming to testify before us today
um
are you in favor or opposed to the bill
because you didn't state it at the
beginning of your and I listened very
carefully to what you said I want to be
sure that I get you correctly
so I'm we are in favor of this bill with
Amendment thank you
thank you representative Tre Levin she
brings up a good point uh when you do
come up and testify initially say
whether you're foreign against uh
representative majority thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question if I heard correctly you said
you put in a petition to zero out the
line for the appropriation in the budget
and I just want to be clear that the the
advocacy for this if I understand it
correctly is to specifically denote that
there is an expenditure for so in your
town
are you suggesting are those funds
co-mingled somehow or is it specific in
your town
so there is a budget line item in the
town budget there's a budget line item
in a School District budget for the for
the school district associate the
um the the School Board Association or
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
it is including the lobbying money but
it also includes all the other services
so what you're forced to do as a
taxpayer we might and I've seen the
benefit of it we have to decide between
taking everything they have to offer or
nothing
we have to we so if we can have to say
we might want some of your Educational
Services which which are great but we
don't want the lobbying part that's the
that's what we're looking to do here and
this is what this law would do to
separate those two things out and then
let the voters decide it's not
preventing it it's just a separate
uh representative
I understand that you support the bill
and you mentioned that you support it
with the amendment what would that
Amendment be
the amendment would be an addition to
RSA 32-5 where you would basically State
something along the lines that a
operating budget cannot contain any
funds that would be used for lobbying
pursuant to RSA 15 1
and that a governing body may may add a
separate special worn article for the
purposes of lobbying funds to be
presented to the voters
a simple two sentence Amendment
question you mentioned in your previous
testimony that frequently and I'm
paraphrasing here so
bear with me uh you mentioned that
frequently the advice of so-called
lobbyists went against the will of the
voters
can you expound on that
well you mean you look at what's parents
parental Bill of Rights for example
they'll they'll testify against it they
testify against updates to collective
bargaining agreements both in the town
and um in the school districts
so it's it's the general consensus and
you heard it from representative Bohm
that the the positions that they take
are almost always I could go through
bill after Bill after Bill and you know
their position is always opposite almost
always opposite of what I and others
like me that are taxpayers and parents
believe that's the best way to concisely
do it you could have a whole hour about
that
thank you Mr chair so
so theoretically if the those same
organizations took positions against
those policies that you specified
what would be your approach in that
scenario
I'm not sure I understand the question
would you still be considered lobbyists
that need warrant articles for approval
if they supported
the legislation or the policies that you
are saying go go against the will of the
voters
I think you have to look at everything
thank you Mr chair
my question is to go back in your
testimony you said you
got the membership as a Marine
for individual you didn't do it as
um
for your organization
correct so you were trying to
Lobby or get Lobby for your personal
gain a personal representation not for
marine
National Guard so
how did you draw the line I I'm still
trying to figure out you know who draws
the line and how do you draw that line
so the point I was trying to make there
is I joined the National Guard
Association National Guard Association
has many services but they also do
lobbying both at the federal and state
level the point is is that the money
that they get is not coming from
taxpayers
it's not coming from tax paying funds
it's coming from individuals that decide
voluntarily to support those
organizations just like the previous
speaker spoke about the fire chiefs
Association that doesn't they're not
using our our the funds raised locally
by taxpayers to pay for that those Fire
Chiefs are paying out of their own funds
their own personal funds because that's
important to them that's the way it
should be taxpayers as a group should
decide if they want to have the lobbying
or if they don't and it could be done on
an annual basis
representative Gallagher
um so just to follow up on
representative stavis's question she was
asking about a statement
um
you made saying that these associations
go against the will of Voters however
the way I remember it was you saying
they went against the will of taxpayers
can you clarify which one of those you
said
I believe I said that it was taxpayers
and parents okay and many of those folks
are also voters are there voters who are
not taxpayers or parents representative
follow-up
you may follow up are are there voters
who are not taxpayers or parents who
deserve to have their interests
that is a that is true that those could
also be cases and they get a vote at the
town or School District meeting if if we
pass if this is passed as a warrant uh
if this went into law then they could
decide to vote for that warn article and
say Yes I want to use my tax dollars for
that purpose
thank you representative Gilman last
question for this witness thank you Mr
chair and thank you Mr power for coming
in
um
aren't the representatives here are
elected by the constituents who you're
talking about individually having a say
so shouldn't this body be all of New
Hampshire as opposed to and we listen to
the lobbyist pro and con and don't have
to take their opinions isn't that what
we're here representing
my my position on this is that the
legislative body in a town or School
District should decide if they want to
support lobbying activities with the
monies raised out of their taxes that
that's a decision that's local decision
that should be done annually that's what
this bill would achieve and that's how
their voice would be heard
thank you
oops thank you Mr power for your
testimony uh next we're going to call uh
and I will remind
you have two minutes two minutes written
down we'll go we'll give you the three
though all right thanks
thank you very much Mr chair uh good
afternoon morning uh members of the
committee my name is bear Christina I'm
the executive director of the New
Hampshire school boards Association we
are opposed to this bill
um I will try and be um as quick as
possible uh Mr chair
um we do reiterate um some of the uh
points that have been made by the New
Hampshire Municipal Association
um a couple asked other aspects relative
to the bill
um while this is targeted at nhma and
the New Hampshire school boards
Association as I'm reading the language
it says for each agency that does
lobbying and another speaker spoke of
how um you know our services are bundled
we provide services to school boards the
same way that the municipal Association
provides services to municipalities we
have a staff attorney that answers phone
calls uh an email is from
superintendents and school board members
we provide hours and hours and hours of
training every year for school boards
across the state
um but there are other agencies and
entities and companies that school
districts pay money to that turn around
and Lobby so I don't know how that can
be bifurcated Xfinity lobbies school
districts pay for cable bills waste
disposal lobbies they pick up the trash
that's that's State money if I'm not
mistaken probably local money because
your adequacy is not paying for your
trash removal
construction companies Waste Management
Comcast eversource Unitil so are we
going to be putting separate warrant
articles on on the school district
warrant for every entity that every
school district pays money to that turns
around and then comes back and lobbies
within this building it's it's a little
bit of it's a little bit absurd the
other aspect to representative boam
talked about
um going against the interest of
taxpayers on the contrary I think nhsba
saves taxpayers lots of money every
single year through dues they're able to
pay my salary my staff attorney's salary
so we can provide the those trainings
for free we don't provide it we don't we
don't charge any additional money
outside of our regular dues for school
board training we travel all over the
state and do dozens and dozens and
dozens of these a year
if they if we didn't exist and we're not
able to provide that sort of training
school districts would be hiring
Attorneys at three or four hundred
dollars an hour and that would be ripped
they did it it would we save money by
them being able to pull their money to
an association like nhsba so we can
provide those resources the last aspect
relative to the bill itself in a
possible proposal that the previous
speaker brought up it's impossible to
know in any given legislative session
how much nhsba spends on lobbying in
part that's due to the number of bills
nhsba is tracking 220 bills this year
probably gonna have our reports are
going to be higher than they would be if
there were only 100 bills so bifurcating
the money every single year you know
this money is for lobbying this money is
for the the other services it it it it'd
be it's impractical and it's impossible
one year I might spend five thousand
dollars five thousand dollars to my
salary might be used for lobbying
another year it might be ten thousand
dollars it depends on the number of
bills and how active nhsba is and how
many bills there are that are impacting
local school districts so the proposal
we you know we disagree with the the
initial bill we oppose the initial bill
and the other proposals don't don't make
any sense either
um I think those are most of the points
that I wanted to make
um
they are indeed you are at three minutes
and 30. I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you for your Indulgence
representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
attorney Christina for taking my
question so in your opening statement
you made the comment that this bill
specifically targets both New Hampshire
Municipal Association in the New
Hampshire School Board Association
reading the text of this bill
um I don't see that could you provide
evidence as to that statement yeah thank
you very much for the question
representative of my my evidence would
be representative boam's opening
statement he was introducing the bill
and the primary target was nhsba in the
municipal Association
representative thank you Mr chair a
quick question you did allude to the
fact that on a in a given year it could
be five or ten thousand even if you go
to the granular level each day is it
practical for you to say I spent two
hours on the phone lobbying for this
three hours for education is that
possible thank you thank you very much
for the question we try and do that as
best as we possibly as best as we
probably possibly can we're open and
transparent with the amount of lobbying
that we do we file all the all the
required quarterly reports register
every year
um as um I believe Mr Gray has said
um the definition of lobbying is also
very challenging I've been sitting in
this room for two hours for an hour and
a half I was checking my email and doing
other work was I lobbying by being here
I don't know we try and be overly
cautious with those reports so you know
I'm not trying to hide anything about it
representative you Keller thank you
thank you for taking the question
um
it if the uh legislature is it is it
true that your your testimony is that if
the legislature said that dues
paid by the um town can own cannot
include lobbying
um and the lobbying efforts would have
to be
um voted on separately for the amount
that that was requested by those
agencies to do lobbying are you saying
that that is
um
impossible for you guys to be able to
adhere to that law if we passed it sure
thank you very much for the for the
question I hope I understood your
question correctly my statement would be
that if if you were at to ask us to sort
of bifurcate the money so let's say your
school district pays three thousand
dollars to nhsba I'm just using this as
an example I'd say 2500 of that is for
our general Services legal policy
training Etc 500 is for the quote
unquote lobbying I don't that that 500
is going to be different every single
year I don't know how much I Lobby in
any given year until I fill out my my
year-end reports meanwhile we've got
annual meetings in March with a certain
number designated on the warrant for how
much of that money is going to nhsba's
lobbying you know I have no idea what my
my March April and May lobbying reports
are going to look like until we get
through them so I have I don't know how
we can bifurcate the money
um without knowing what mine and anybody
else's lobbying expenses is going to
look like at the end of the year I can't
bifurcate that out until
I I just don't I don't I don't know how
we would be able to do that
representative
representative Brown
thank you Mr chairman so from a
practical perspective let's say 25 of
the towns did a warrant article and said
we don't want you to lobby for us
anymore but the rest of the towns in the
states said no we're good with that how
would that change your lobbying efforts
sure thank you very much I mean we'd
have to find a way to sort of
restructure our dues and just to be
clear to the lobbying efforts um are are
not the same as nhma but we have it what
we call our delegate assembly every
school board that's a member it's like
an annual meeting it's our annual
meeting essentially and school boards
submit what would be akin to a
petitioned warrant article they
submitted nhsba opposes X Y and Z and
hsba supports X Y and Z our board of
directors then gives it a yes recommend
no recommend that carries absolutely no
weight at all and then we put it out to
the body we put it out to the devil gets
that show up and they vote on our
representative Bowman's been to them I'd
been a number of them
um when he was still on his school board
15 or so years ago so it's it's not me
thinking this is a good idea it's not my
board of directors thinking yes on this
bill no on this bill the positions that
we take here at the uh at the at the
legislature are are dictated by our
members telling us what we want to do
and one point on that a statement was
made that nhsba opposed you're no longer
answering uh representative Brown's
questions and I I'll reiterate a grant
again please if you're answering a
question try to keep it as concise as uh
possible we don't need to hear
repetition uh representative stavis
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um this this bill seeks to put in the
hands of the voters
of a given town this decision and I'm
trying to put myself in the position of
a voter in a town who's not on the
school board not on the planning board
not on the city council or the board of
Selectmen
what level of information
does the average citizen have about
whether to say yay or nay on this one
line item in a very long budget thank
you for the question representative I
mean that's a that's a great question I
suppose
um you know if you're attentive to your
budget and you're one of those people
that reads every line item before your
annual meeting reach out to your your
board chair and or your superintendent
or your business administrator and say
line item one two three what is this
five thousand dollars for and hopefully
you'll get a coach and answer
um you know in terms of sort of the
taxpayer aspect I mean your local budget
is in the hands of the taxpayer as well
too budgets can be amended one way or
the other at your annual meeting or your
deliberative session
thank you for your testimony uh one
quick
one final question I have for you then
we have to move on to the next um
speaker
um you mentioned it a few times about
dues and uh structured how are they
structured sure um it's an uh it's a
good question are bylaws have a um uh a
provision
um that the dues are based on the amount
of local money raised in that particular
District excluding Capital costs and
excluding any federal funds
um I will say um my board of directors
and I have had conversations about
amending that I would also like to say
we have not raised dues in probably 12
or 13 years because we brought a tight
ship specifically how are they
calculated so there's there's a there's
a I I could probably be easier for me to
send it to your representative or Mr
chair there's a calculation formula
based on the amount of local money
raised that would be fine if you send us
an example of that that would be sure
thank you okay uh we are going to move
on to the next speaker uh next testifier
thank you Mr chair uh Dan hilly uh
Nashua city clerk representing New
Hampshire City and town clerks
Association and we are opposed to this
bill currently our association collects
twenty dollars annually as an
association dues for each town in city
across the state all of our funds
whether from association dues or raise
as a result of Raffles other sales in
our conference proceeds they go into one
account so be hard for us to separate
our current funds that we have to to pay
our lobbyists and we need to open
additional accounts to store these funds
if the bill passes one of the big
concerns we have with this bill
is that it says it takes effect within
60 days of passage which wouldn't be
enough time for towns most towns that
have a March
election to get this question on the
ballot for this year so it would pose a
problem until we can sort through what
money we we raise from association dues
and what money we raise from
um
other other proceeds
until that until towns and cities could
actually get this on the ballot to
separate those funds
um we as an association try to follow
bills that directly affect the functions
of our job but we can't always attend
hearings
and that's where we rely on our
lobbyists to give us uh reports so
we rely on the information that they
send us so we can stay informed a lot of
bills that we follow and track they
directly affect us so we're opposed to
this bill and we agree with the uh the
letter that the nhma handed out to you
reopens any questions
thank you for your testimony reps
representative manager Puti thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um
oh
plus gone sorry representative Kelly you
have a question
yes thank you
and thank you for uh testifying you said
that it would be hard or difficult to
separate the amounts
would you be able to comply with the law
if we if we changed it so that dues are
if lobbying monies are not allowed to be
included in dues would you be able to
comply with that we'd be able to comply
we'd have to create an additional
account yes
um on the 60 days it would be tough
60 days from Passage thank you seeing no
more questions thank you for your
testimony thank you last pink card
anybody else as I don't have any more
[Music]
good morning
Mr chair could you pull the mic a little
good morning Mr chair and honorable
members of the municipal County and
County government committee my name is
Donna ma Burkett
I'm a former member of this illustrious
committee while serving the towns of New
Boston and Mount Vernon and I am
currently I currently serve as the chair
of the New Boston select board
thank you for your attention to my
testimony regarding HB 51 and in the
interest of your valuable time I will
keep it brief
I urge you to vote in expedient to
legislate on HB 51.
HB 51 serves to remove the authority of
local governing and legislative bodies
to determine the municipality's
expenditures on predominantly of
predominantly local tax revenue
as a select board member I'm required to
manage the Prudential Affairs of the
Town including the development of a
budget that serves the needs of our
community
as citizens of our town have the
privilege and responsibility of
reviewing and voting to approve or
reject
line items in our budget
so to consider a mandate
by legislators
on what and what cannot be paid for by
predominantly local tax dollar seems in
overreach
most of the members of this committee
are elected officials or serve their
cities and towns in other capacities
I would venture a guess that you and the
staff of your municipality have availed
themselves to the thousands of hours of
training and depth of expertise provided
by organizations
such as the New Hampshire cities and
town clerks Association
the building officials Association the
association of assessing officials
and the New Hampshire School Board
Association just to name a few
unless we forget the New Hampshire
Municipal Association
whose Financial legal and operations
expertise is available to assist local
officials
and others with valuable information and
training that cannot be obtained by any
other organization or individual
while there may be some legislators who
do not agree with all the positions
taken by such advocacy groups HB 51
mandates the funding for such
memberships be identified specifically
in a warrant article for every city and
town
but recall
that citizens currently have the ability
to sponsor petitioned warrant articles
for consideration by local voters
in conclusion
HP 51 is an overreach of the New
Hampshire legislature to mandate
the inclusion of a specific warrant
article for municipal governing and
legislative bodies to address
the Mandate undermines the current
process of local decisions of spending
and policy that assures that each
municipality maintains the its unique
Community character
I repeat please vote in expedient to
legislate on HP 51 thank you thank you
for your testimony questions
representative yakella
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
if if a voter goes to the municipal and
County Government website and reads
their policies and believes that their
money their tax money should not be
um going towards that policy
um
under current law there's in in the fact
that they don't break down
um their efforts for training versus
lobbying
is there any way for the local
Warren article as you suggested to
defund the the
um lobbying efforts while still allowing
them to uh Retreat
access the training that Municipal and
County government
um uh or Municipal Association currently
offers
and if not would this bill now allow or
Empower that voter to be able to have
that opportunity thank you the building
its current state does not allow that so
I I would have I'm only I'm answering a
question related to the current status
of the bill and what it says so to
answer your specific question about
splitting
um I would have to leave that to the
organizations to make that decision if
one citizen decided to do a petition
Warren article it would have to be
addressed
that's that's about all I could answer
that
representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so you had stated in
in your testimony that um
State Statute allows a line item veto of
any particular budget item so
historically with regards to the the
town of New Boston have serving on you
serving on the select board could you
provide us with examples in the past
say like five seven years where there
have been in fact an attempt to zero out
a particular line item in the budget and
did it pass thank you I apologize to
have to tell you that I really have only
been involved in this particular
position this is my second of three
years so during my tenure that has not
happened however during
um budget meetings those questions
certainly do come up in terms of talking
about what the purpose of it is the
money spent but we've not had anybody uh
request that uh budget line item be
representative manager Puti thank you Mr
chair thank you
honorable member cat for taking my
question
um you mentioned about advocacy and
lobbying going kind of two sides of coin
in that sense so would this how would
in way of splitting it's almost seems
like a splitting hair so is that is it
the correct analogy or no
I'm not I'm sorry I'm not sure I
understand your question sorry can I
restate my question yes uh if you can
state it concisely and clearly please
okay
in your testimony you alluded to the
term advocacy and lobbying so there are
some issues that you might approach the
uh specific Association to lobby for
that on behalf of the voters the
taxpayers
in some uh instances it could be an
advocacy would you reach out to your
local uh elected officials to advocate
um if I was acting in an official
capacity yes I would have a conversation
with all of the leaders of all of the
Departments
um
um to make sure that we were all in the
same
page
but you know I I think what we're
looking at here is the possibility of
having well it actually isn't really a
possibility you look at all of the
select boards uh and other elected
officials who many have full-time jobs
they will not be sitting here
um
talking about what their issues are
because they they actually ask someone
else to do that for them
um but I can assure you that if there
are issues that we would disagree with
as a board that we felt was not good for
our citizens and that's what we're
elected to do
um then we would certainly let
um those organizations know that we are
opposed to what they're doing
it's our job
thank you for your testimony
uh seeing no more hands and I have no
more pink cards we'll uh close the
hearing on HB 51 on the blue sheet we
had five individ four individuals one
four and three against
uh we are going to go ahead now and open
up the uh hearing public hearing on hb12
relative to petitions for Warren
articles
the hearing on 312 is open pink cards
give put over by the blue sheet if you
have pink cards please do not uh
thank you uh representative Malloy I
believe you are the primed your floor
yes
thank you very much thank you Mr chair
members of the committee I appreciate
your time today and we will just have a
couple of folks to speak so hopefully
that we'll uh get through this pretty
quickly
for the record my name is Dennis Malloy
and I represent Rockingham District 24
the towns of Greenland and Rye New
Hampshire and I'm here to introduce HB
312 relative to petitions for Warrant
articles at a special meeting
the bill is based upon a request from
voters in Greenland New Hampshire the
town Administration and the town clerk
it is also supported by the Town
Administrator and the select board in
Rye and Northampton
today you will hear testimony how local
officials are affected by current law
when a petition for a special meeting is
presented you'll hear about the
unbudgeted expense
the time and energy expended by Town
staff to meet the requirements for
conducting a special meeting
I want to be clear that this bill does
not eliminate the provision for a
special meeting it simply changes the
current requirement of 50 registered
voters
and changing the number 50 to 10 percent
of the Town registered voters to bring
forward a petition the bill includes how
that 10 number is uh
is arrived at
it also keeps in place the requirement
of the signatures of at least 25
registered voters to move a
petition-worn article onto the March
town meeting ballot so that they're
still relatively easy access to the
ballot uh occurring for any anybody in
town who wants to petition
if I may I want to take a moment to
recognize Greenland's town clerk
and past chair of New Hampshire town
clerk's Association Marge Morgan who was
planning on being here today but due to
an illness in her office she is in
Greenland
and uh doing people's business because
she's there to make sure the office
stays open but I want to thank her for
her help in crafting
the direction of this bill
uh with that uh I'll be happy to take
any questions and uh
turn this over to the next speakers
thank you thank you representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question so
you mentioned a number of you mentioned
that this bill is a basically a
constituent request and you had listed
out a number of towns which I wasn't
able to to write down but my question is
um
with regards to those particular towns
that you cited how many special meetings
have these towns been petitioned to to
have
are there any others with questions
representative Guthrie
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
the question
legislation to make it more difficult to
have a special town meeting
and is that and is that a good thing or
a bad thing
if it is so
the it's really
the the thrust of this bill
was more focused on helping our town
officials conduct uh the election in
March in a much more efficient way what
happens is if there's if there's a
special meeting requested and anytime
outside of the period in the run-up to
the uh March Town meetings
you will hear some specifics on what it
costs Greenland to do this uh in terms
of real dollars and time and treasure
and energy and resources and that's
really what this is all about it's about
the uh distraction of of town P Town
employees doing their job for all the
taxpayers in the town all right thank
you thank you for taking my question
welcome thank you representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question I
live in a city
yeah so this is you know Terra Incognito
for me could you educate me please on
what the experience is for Town
employees and and members of Select
boards when they are petitioned for a
special meeting what is what does that
mean for you thank you Representatives
Davis
I will defer that question if you don't
mind to the next speaker uh Mr Paul
Sanderson who has some very specific
represent power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking an additional question so um the
language of this bill it it's increasing
the threshold to have with regards to
the
number of signatures it's raising it to
ten percent
where did this number come from
to me it seems high
uh the that was a conversation that I
had with uh
uh Marge Morgan Our Town Clerk and
others uh in the town about where uh we
felt that would be a reasonable number
uh there are
I'm not
completely sure
specifically how many registered voters
there are in Greenland it's around uh 25
maybe 3 000. so uh it would give you
some idea of how many signatures we
would need for a special meeting
otherwise you only need 25 for a special
for a petition Warren article during the
town the March uh deliberative session
and town meeting it doesn't change that
so if you really wanted to put an item
on the ballot you'd only need to get 25
signatures for the March meeting
follow up thank you Mr chairman and so
with regards to the the language in this
bill on lines 14 through 16. there the
pres current language is struck out so
it it makes two different categories in
towns with less than a thousand
inhabitants there's one criteria and um
in towns with greater than ten thousand
inhabitants there's uh the specification
of five percent so
um
why was were these two categories uh
struck in the language and therefore
with the amended language
regardless of how large or small a
particular municipality is
there's this requirement in the language
of the bill that
any municipality has the ten percent
could you ex speak to why this
distinction was is eliminated in The
Bill thank you for the question that's
uh
I appreciate that
when I presented this to uh OLS and
asked them about what we wanted to try
to accomplish here uh that was the
recommendation they made on drafting the
bill to go this route and I uh just
agreed to that in terms of what I used
their experience in this to help move
excuse me representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um
I was wondering
is this the only way
that a special election can be called in
a town and kind of a follow-up if I may
add it to that at the same time no we do
uh
I
I'm not an elections expert
uh
I that question may may be able to be
answered by representative the gentleman
behind you is shaking his head no so I'm
assuming he'll be able to answer yeah
I'm sure I didn't want to turn away from
you to uh yeah thank you my follow-up
was can a board of five call for a
special meeting of a town that's why I
was like the select board
again I will defer that question to uh
Mr Sanderson thank you any further
questions for the
representative Malloy
seeing none thank you thank you so much
it was I served on this Committee in my
first term in the house in 2012 and I
appreciate your work it's complex and
time consuming and I appreciate that
thank you very good uh next we do have I
believe the gentleman standing sitting
behind you Paul Sanderson is that
correct
foreign
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Paul Sanderson I'm
currently serving as the Town
Administrator in the town of Greenland
but I previously served on the select
board planning board Zoning Board of
adjustment and budget Committee in our
town over a period of the last 30 years
as well as serving as the moderator of
the school district and moderator at the
town of various meetings
during that period of time I also served
for 10 years as a staff attorney at New
Hampshire Municipal Association where I
would be answering questions such as you
posed on a daily basis
so if I may start with some of the
questions that you have already asked
the first question you asked is are
special meetings something that occurs
every year no the answer is that they
are relatively rare
in answering the second question is this
the only way that a special meeting can
be called it's the way that the citizens
can seek uh that for a special meeting
to be called however the board of
Selectmen in a particular Town also have
the ability to call a special meeting
for the consideration of questions but
there are significant statutory limits
that are imposed upon selectment because
usually it's about appropriating money
or resending a particular appropriation
and I would refer you to RSA 31 colon 5
which requires a finding by the superior
court that an emergency exists and that
becomes the predicate towards calling a
special meeting unless for whatever
reason you would hope that one half of
the voters in your town would actually
be present in voting on the particular
question something which is almost
impossible to achieve
uh and so I believe those are the
primary questions that have been asked
so far and I'm here really to support
this legislation because it begins to
provide a level of protection to towns
such as mine against uh special meetings
that are called just to deal with a
particular question
uh in our case we had uh citizens in the
community uh
seek a special meeting in order to ban
the use of voting machines it was an
election question that started in August
of 21 and by the time we had dealt with
that through the deliberative session
and conducting an official ballot
because we are an sb2 formatted town the
entire amount of money that we spent is
somewhere between 26 and 30 thousand
dollars to complete that particular
process
in my written testimony I've also tried
to point out to you that there is no
limitation in current law for the number
of times that citizens can do this
during a particular year
so that we could go from special meeting
to special meeting to special meeting
because there is very little in the way
of legal standard that is contained in
the statute that would allow the board
of Selectmen to stop the process even if
the article seems on its face to be
particularly illegal
let me give you a hypothetical in that
situation let's suppose that we conclude
our annual town meeting where a question
has come up about purchasing a fire
truck and the answer is in the negative
and now we have people who really wanted
to have that fire truck uh petition to
by this application process to have a
special time meeting to consider the uh
purchase of a fire truck you would say
oh my well that can't be done because
that would obviously be a new
appropriation and that would violate RSA
31.5 the answer to that is no the
selectman would not be able to stop the
process because in a deliberative
session the language of that particular
warrant article is amendable and could
remove that particular appropriation and
instead put in other forms of directives
before it was taken to the official
ballot
selectman right now under RSA 39 3 have
a difficult task because it in the in
the event they refuse to call that
special meeting they could be brought to
a circuit court and found guilty of a
violation fined personally and have
money extracted for the benefit of the
town
that's in RSA 3913 and so that is why we
asked for representative malloy's help
to try to bring this issue forward to
show the vulnerability the towns have in
this particular statute
and to ask for some form of Standards or
relief to make it more difficult for
those negative aspects to occur there
had been a question as well as to
whether this can happen in cities the
answer is no this particular statute
applies only to towns so it applies to
towns that have a regular Town format
regular town meeting format or an sb2
format in the sb2 format the fiscal
impact is going to be larger due to the
bifurcation of the meetings between a
deliberative session and the need to
conduct an official ballot proceeding as
opposed to a town meeting where things
could be handled orally by either a
Voice vote or a written ballot conducted
at one meeting
uh with that in mind I'd be happy to
answer questions
thank you for your testimony any
questions
I see none thank you very much for your
testimony we have one final uh
hi my name is Alice passer and I live in
Greenland thank you for the opportunity
to speak in favor of this bill I was
involved in the effort to defeat this uh
special Warren article uh because it was
harmful for our town and our town
officials it so happens that this
special election that caused us to have
a vote with one question on it fell on
the Saturday before Christmas
we were happy that we defeated it on a
nine to one vote but I think the point
of this this bill is
um you know we we experienced uh how
costly this was and how few people in
our town supported it we'd like to raise
the the threshold whereby a special
election could be triggered in a town
like ours because it was very very
costly I could certainly imagine
citizens having issues with our town
whereby a special election would be
warranted but
um we'd like to see more more people in
the town buy into this with the the 10
percent uh 10 percent of signatures
required in order to protect our town
from from you know time and and money
that was spent on on on this effort or
to see somehow
um you know obviously this is not
changing for um for things added to our
town elections it will still be a low
threshold of signatures uh for for a
petitioned Warren article to be added to
our town elections but we'd like to see
the trigger for a special election
changed thank you very much
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
so it
you stated that you're a resident of
Greenland and that you cited this
particular special meet special meeting
that was petitioned and occurred
recently historically in the past seven
years how many special meetings has the
town of Greenland
um been petitioned to to conduct this is
representative
I'm sorry
that'll be heard you know
the
the bills calls for
10 of the registered voters in the town
is this town sb2 town
and
do you
deliberative session
well I I believe it is for small towns
like ours in sb2 town is that correct
um and uh we I don't we had about 150
people at our special election at our
deliberative session excuse me
um for for this prior to the election
you know deliberative session is
triggered by the by the petitioned award
article as is the special election
so did you I'm sorry sir did you ask
about the deliberative session or about
how many people voted
well just mainly the
did you have enough people to show up
from the I'm sorry Mr chair if I make
um follow-up question thank you
the
did you have a quota that you know this
this States 10 of the registered voters
have to apply for the special meeting it
says nothing about how many people have
I mean you could you could go with
10 people excuse me representative I'm
sorry I'm testifying go ahead
was there a question I don't think so
there was oh there was if you have
another question go ahead
well you know I I was just asking if
there was enough if you if you feel that
it's worth
having that the meeting to
with so few people
are they being represented
well it's my understanding
um if you know there was 10 of the
signatures to trigger a special meeting
and and then a special election uh
hopefully the people in the town would
be interested and show up for the
special meeting
seeing no further questions thank you
very much for your testimony I have no
more pink cards the blue sign-in sheet I
have two four and four against and with
that we will close the hearing on HB
313.
and we will now open up the hearing on
HB 313 relative to the reduction from
the default budget per official budget
representative yokella you are up
foreign
thank you Mr chair
thank you members
um
relative to
default budgets and this bill stemmed
from
my attendance on my local municipal
budget committee and the fact that our
recent
um
budget came
in significantly under the well a
hundred thousand plus the proposed
budget and so I asked the um
the person that prepared the budget what
was the main reason for the cause of the
default budget being significantly under
the proposed budget and they said that
it was because of turnover
because under the current RSA if you
have for example an employee that is
hired for a hundred thousand dollars and
they leave the position and you hire a
new person for fifty thousand dollars
that hundred thousand dollars stays in
the default budget even though the
proposed budget and everyone knows that
you only need fifty thousand dollars for
that position
but there's no way under our current law
to
um remove that extra fifty thousand
dollars from the default budget
artificially inflating that default
budget and
um
so what I tried to do was to make it
clear that um so if the if the position
was completely eliminated and we got a
new position
for that uh that would not be the whole
amount for the hundred thousand dollars
would be removed from the default budget
and so that isn't really a a good
solution
um to to essentially eliminate and
recreate a new position
um and so this proposed language
um I have added to the default budget
language saying that any salary and
benefit reductions as part of position
turnover which occur before the public
meeting so you actually know that the
person is hired it's not just that
you're you know someone left and the the
position is out for
um you know we're we're trying to hire
someone you may need that flexibility of
to be able to hire the fifty thousand
dollar person or a seventy thousand
dollar person or a hundred thousand
dollar person
um and so I'm just trying to limit it to
the the situations where you know you've
already hired they've the so the
contract is signed before the public
hearing that the new
um salary for that position and benefits
is at that quote fifty thousand dollar
level like I just said in the example
um and so
um it's in the new budget at the fifty
thousand dollars I think that it should
be reflected as as fifty thousand
dollars in the default budget in that
case
some some places May
um have the interpretation that that
this is already
um
required that this change is already
required but
um
based on the budget budget trainings or
for default budget that I went to and
um the law just doesn't specifically
state that you would need to reduce it
by that and so I'm just trying to
clarify that and make sure that
that these default budgets are are
appropriate for what is needed for the
town to run so thank you for the
question
thank you for your testimony
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for introducing this bill
my question pertains to the the amended
language on line 13. and specifically
I'm looking at the adjective Municipal
in relation to budget committee
so under RSA 3214
it specifies an official budget
committee and we also some
municipalities have advisory budget
committees or Finance committees which
has no statutory
Authority and that's under 32 colon 24.
so my question is well why
are you what is meant by Municipal
budget Committee in in
do you want to have this ability
um
for either a budget committee or a
finance committee and additionally
in municipalities that do not have
either then that budget belongs to the
governing body which would be the select
board or the school board so would you
also would it be better to include that
provisional language if
none of those
finance budget committees exist thank
you
um the
um for allowing me to address the
amendment so the amendment is not my
amendment that is a
another person's amendment that um that
I think should be considered on its own
merits whether or not it should be
adopted
um it is that the member is here and
will testify to that uh Amendment
um I think that
um the lack of clarity in default
budgets is pervasive and
um the member uh has their own story
about their own time on their budget
committee and the the struggles that
they had and wanted a vehicle for being
able to amend this this statute and
since my my bill is on the statute
already they uh it's a germane Amendment
and so
um they were able to offer it and they
will be able to speak to
their Amendment and we can choose to
representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question I
I just
um it's I think one of the last things
you said about the bill when we talk
about the line previous to the one in
bold so I guess that would be line seven
where it talks about salaries and
benefits positions that have been
eliminated I'm curious if you could
restate for me or or how your language
enhances that or is it different because
I'm not I'm not I'm not quite sure what
the difference is between eliminated and
turnover
thank you thank you for the question
um
so eliminated is is
um completely gone from the budget like
Struck from the budget you have you know
employee maintenance manager and no now
you just have maintenance employee and
you're eliminating the manager position
and you're going to hire a different
position that would be eliminating but
if you had a manager and then the
manager left and you're just hiring on
another manager that's turnover and so
so right now under current law If you
eliminate the
um you know the maintenance manager
position and just strike it entirely
that will be removed from the default
budget but if you happen to have
currently have a d uh you know a
maintenance manager that's hired at 75
000 and then you have turnover in your
new higher your new uh maintenance
manager is only at fifty thousand there
would that would not be currently
reflected in the default budget and I'm
just trying to have that be able to be
reflected
representative Guthrie
thank you
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question and you should you're
to be commended to try to do anything to
make any clarity as you said into about
a default budget I think I understated
it when you said that there was it was
lack of clarity would uh
uh well you know you you don't have the
the Amendments so we have to talk about
the bill uh
I would say that the only question I
have is uh
is
I'm looking at line 10 is that
uh is that a change in the uh in the
amendment too it says shall we
Appropriations not likely to recur which
opens Pandora's Box means it can be
anything representative that is current
language is that is that in in the
amendment strike it
that is that is the amendment that is
not my language and so I I suggest that
you ask those the questions regarding
um not likely to occur and all that for
the member that's that wants to amend
the discount thank you I will do that
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and uh
representative Yokel I'd like to
apologize for my confusion I have too
many sheets in front of me and I have
notes and I went to the wrong sheet so I
apologize for speaking to the amendment
which we're not dealing with right now
representative majority you had to
follow it thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative for taking a
follow-up so this is just for my clarity
again so the position
turnover if that position is unfilled
it still can REM it it's in transition
it has been posted at maybe a less than
what it had originally been filled we're
still good to leave it as such correct
yeah under my under this language
the the turnover has to occur before the
public hearing the actual like if you
post because just because you posted at
fifty thousand dollars even though it
was previously 75 doesn't mean you're
going to be able to fill it and so maybe
you're gonna need to repost it at 75
once no one applies for it right so
we'll want to leave that flexibility
open while there's still kind of you're
in this limbo zone of not having
employment but once you've filled that
and signed on the dotted line that
turnover has occurred before the public
hearing so thank you any further
questions
seeing none thank you very much
representative yokella next week call
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
for letting me speak here today uh my
name is representative sellers I
represent Grafton 18 which is at uh
flutorial including all 10 towns in
southern Grafton
I won't list the towns but in any case
um I support this
uh House Bill 313
and as I noticed that it was going in
for
uh as a House Bill I said oh this is a
good time to maybe help get some clarity
to the RSA 4013 9 lowercase b
and that's what I'm trying to do here is
bring some clarity and understanding
because I've been on the town budget
committee and also the school board
budget committee and I've seen how the
budget committees work and experienced
them firsthand for at least six years
now
so what I'm trying to do is two things
here one is to turn allow the budget
committee if there is a budget committee
to determine what a one-time expense is
all right
the
second part of this or might be reversed
but the second part is
defining which year from last year to
next year's but because believe it or
not there's confusion
there's actually confusion and what you
have is we we get it in uh from the SAU
that the uh well that's not going to
happen next year but it might happen in
a year from now or two years from now so
we get that type of language from the
SAU
I'm hoping that just by putting this uh
additional language in will actually
help some to clear up this RSA because
it's it's actually kind of vague when it
comes to one-time expenses we have for
an example
um they put in a floor buffer a ten
thousand dollar floor buffer which is
going to be replaced once every 10 years
and they know it's going to be replaced
once in every 10 years but it's in the
budget and they leave that ten thousand
dollar flow buffer in there you have
um risers for the for the choir or the
of course I say quiet excuse me of
course but in kitties in that case there
you know that's another 20 to 25 000
budget item which they know is going to
last again for another 15 to 25 years
but it's left in the budget because this
RSA is vague and what happens we end up
going back and forth and what they do is
get their Council involved which ends up
costing the school district
actually more money at that point so I'm
not going to go on from there I just
want to Simply bring this forward if
this is the exact language that's used
going forward fantastic if you find that
a it needs to be cleared up even a
little bit more awesome I just want to
bring It Forward I'll take any questions
thank you representative sellers are
there any questions representative
Guthrie
thank you and thank you for taking my
question uh is this a method of having
more eyes and more confusion in trying
to determine which items should go in or
out of the default budget
uh thank you for the question the
the only eyes that are on this at this
point here would be the elected budget
committee or the select board slash
either School Board which would be
looking at these one-time expenditures
so they are listed in the uh as
expenditures as far as breakouts and how
much they are so it's just their job as
elected officials they're supposed to be
looking at these but the problem is is
determining is oh that's not a one-time
expense this one is and then you end up
getting counsel in there and then you
end up spending more money for the
district so we're trying to we're trying
to just get it to whatever the budget
committee says or the select board if
there is no budget committee or School
Board their their word is final
follow up Mr fewman follow up uh and
just question pretty much the same
question but I guess is this just too
many cooks I mean this is a very
vague area on the Senate Bill 2 was
awful that we even put it in but we have
it now that we have it isn't it better
to have somebody do it as an
administrative item and then in the in
the uh deliberative session uh that's
the time to take a look if anybody wants
to take a look at how the default was
was determined
I guess that is a possibility in the
deliberative session on asb2 absolutely
and of course that Tom meeting and every
time you go to town meeting it's it's a
bottom line budget so always keep that
in mind and and still this would still
be a bottom line budget so even though
you might want a saying this is a
actually I take that back the default
budget cannot be changed this is the
default budget so when you go in sb2 you
can only talk about the proposed budget
I can appreciate that so it just seemed
to me that we have too many cooks
already looking at uh regular questions
thank you for your answers
I see none thank you very much
representative sellers thank you all uh
good afternoon Mr chairman and the rest
of the committee my name is Scott gross
I am the business administrator for
sau19 which is Goffstown and New Boston
and I'm here to oppose the bill the way
it's written and offer some hopefully
some clarification for you as someone
who is in the trenches who has to
prepare uh the default budget I did
bring goffstown's default budget with me
um essentially I'm here to discuss just
some of the mechanics of preparing the
default budget and budgets in general we
start our process in July but a lot of
the heavy lifting starts in September so
one of the concerns that I had and I'm
so glad that representative vocella uh
articulated what what the premise is the
rationale behind the bill all I was
seeking was to give us a better timeline
so whenever you do budgets or financials
you have to do a snapshot in time our
snapshot in time is typically in
September so contrary to when some folks
were saying that
you want to go all the way up to the
public hearing for us it's probably
about 90 days before that public hearing
where we take that snapshot in time and
in that snapshot in time if we had staff
turnover we're taking the current
incumbent in that role let's say on
September 1st or 15th whatever it may be
and that's the number that we use now I
recognize that the default budget is
contentious that it is interpreted
differently from municipality to
municipality from school to school
district I tend to take a more
conservative approach to the default
budget having served on budget
committees select boards and school
boards I served on all of those I tend
to take a more conservative approach but
what I would would say is that we need
we need more of a snapshot the whole
rolling trying to it's so hard to do
these budgets I I'm responsible for over
70 million dollars of budgets and to
worry about I have to worry you go all
the way to say a public hearing date
which was recently a couple of weeks ago
to then adjust all these numbers and
then get it on the warrant and it is
just really challenging so I would offer
a friendly suggestion to maybe perhaps
say 90 days prior to your public hearing
is you take that snapshot in time the
other one thing that I thought was
interesting was that to me the default
budget needs to be fair and I was a
little taken aback by any salary and
benefit reductions as part of the
position it should be changes sometimes
there's a positive where you have to
adjust your your default budget so um so
you know with that I just again mine was
more of the mechanics of somebody who
has to do it day in and day out and
speaking with my peers who are fellow
business administrators
um
it the timelines are just so so
challenging and we're under the gun to
get to meet all these deadlines and
statutory requirements so unless there
are any questions that that was really
my point today
thank you for your testimony uh
representative and sure thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question which I hope is a quick one I'm
a member of the select board in my town
the select board sets the default budget
it does the school board set their
default budget
uh that's an excellent question in uh in
my town uh which is Goffstown they do I
would also
um
state that in this other Amendment where
the other Amendment says
um
you're going to make your adjustments as
determined by the municipal budget
committee that's a bit of a
contradiction to RSA 40 colon 14b in my
town there was a an article to have the
budget committee set the default budget
and it was it was defeated and I I think
that that's another one that there's a
lot of conflict there because if the
municipality or School District wants
the budget committee to set the default
budget then they're going to vote to do
that what this does is it kind of parses
that out and it allows them to determine
what's a one-time expenditure and what's
not and as an example you know this is
mine so for Goffstown and I'll give you
a good example we did a Windows we did
some windows replacement that was a
one-time expenditure and I put reduced
based upon one-time expenditure there
was another one we had to do a ten
thousand dollar cistern inspection at
our Middle School took it off uh because
it was not going to be reoccurring so so
utilities I take a conservative approach
if the price of propane or electricity
goes up that's new spending for me I
know others may be different but and I
know I recognize the fact that it is
vague but
I take more conservative approach and um
I I think that in this case
um long-winded answer I think the Local
School Board of municipality My Town set
that default budget but we do have to
share it and we share it at public
hearing by the way not at deliberative
the statute says that you have to share
your um your your default budget at
public hearing and that's another thing
is that I set this thing and the board
votes on it typically in December of
every year so that we can then you know
give it to the give it to the um the
voters put it on our website so it's
very transparent public trust is so
important and this is all about our
integrity with the numbers and if you
don't have that public trust people
don't support you on your budgets
further questions representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for
slipping and saying my name
um thank you for taking my question what
percentage of your budget is personnel
which could be fluctuating
um for me and say let's say Goffstown
and New Boston it's about 75 give or
take but it in school districts that's
typically the case it's 70 80 percent is
highly salary and benefits on the
municipal side so when I was on the
board of Selectmen select board now they
call it
um it was far less because you have much
greater Capital costs you know your
roads Bridges
um probably more like 50 60 percent is
so um again it varies from town to town
and it varies based upon town or School
District
representative stavis
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um as I said before I live in a city so
a lot of this is Greek To Me
um
but I'm struck by the professionalism
with which you bring
to your budget process and I'm thinking
that this is a level of professionalism
that that all towns should rightfully
expect of their budget officers and
other professionals that they hire in
this field I'm less convinced that it's
the job of the State Legislature
to get into the business of policing how
professional that process is
representative is there a question in
there
a good question Mr chair I hear no
questions would you would you say that
this is more of a a matter of
how different professionals carry out
their jobs in all of New Hampshire's
towns as opposed to what's written in
state law about how budgets are created
does that make sense
it does but I believe it's a difficult
question to answer
um I believe that everyone has different
opinions on things and uh opinions
that's why there are lawyers
because they interpret statute and what
what they mean
um that being said I do agree with you
that business officials business
administrators like myself
um do take this very seriously and
[Music]
it's also discussed in public session
just so that folks understand the
default budget again I can't speak for
my peers but I present the default
budget so I prepare it for my school
board I don't sign this is by penalty of
perjury I don't sign it my school board
does I have to explain and we go through
it I might give them 20 to
20 items that are basically in my
opinion this is a default item in my
opinion this is new spending and
sometimes I would say ninety percent of
the time if not more they agree with my
my assessment but at the end of the day
it's the governing body who then signs
this and there have been times where
um they have said no I I don't think
that is new spending we believe it's
default and they take a vote and I
change it on the form I mean it it's
happened but it's happened rarely thank
you representative Galler
um so
this
um so you touched on this a little bit
um
in your response to representative
maggiore's question uh but I'd like to
go a bit more into the um amendment that
representative sellers proposed to this
um you said you opposed the bill as
written
um do you think that representative
sellers
Amendment
I just want to make sure I'm speaking
answering it's this one
yeah
2023.0059h yeah I I believe I believe
from sitting in the audience that the
intentions of the representative
sponsoring this bill the amendments are
kind of noble ones they're trying to
clarify it I just don't know if it if
the second one or even the first one
actually does that
um that being said you know if this
committee uh does believe that an
amendment is needed for this particular
statute all I'm asking is that you make
two considerations uh consider a
timeline please do not go all the way to
the public hearing that is just a an
Abomination it would be so challenging
to do
um make it 90 days 120 days to set that
Benchmark and and also factor in that
default budgets go up and down so it's
not just reductions it could be just be
changes so that those are the two things
representative
thank you Mr chairman just a quick
question have you ever had a budget uh
refused that you had in by your town so
that they had to use your default budget
I have been in this world no place okay
that would be yes in Goffstown no in my
four and a half years of doing this job
thank you very much
seeing no further questions thank you
very much last uh pink card I have
nature
thank you Mr chair Nate Grace for the
municipal Association uh we do oppose
this bill but I do want to thank the the
prime sponsor for reaching out and
speaking with us
um this is incredibly complex area of of
law
um I do want to address two things uh
very briefly
um won the proposed amendment
um representative Guthrie asked a
question about that
um and I think
basically that just illustrates the
Perpetual struggle between the budget
committee and governing body
um that's that's just my opinion of it
um and secondly there was a discussion
about the term reductions in line 10 I
mean whether that should be changes and
we at the municipal Association get in
trouble quite frequently because we have
to explain to uh Municipal officials
that inflationary costs
um including
raises that are on separate warrant
articles do not qualify as a reoccurring
costs and therefore could not be
included in the default budget so those
those amounts should not go up
um so I I know that representative
yokella is not here but we had a very
extensive discussion about that term so
I wanted to make sure that I made the
committee aware of that
and that's how I had
thank you
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Graves for taking my question so it my
question I'm not going to restate my
misplaced question of the Prime sponsor
but it pertains to line 13 and the use
of the word Municipal budget committee
um do you see any concerns with that
language and if so what would you
suggest
might be a change to clarify to make it
more clear what's going on there and
what
so intention is at at the risk of
getting myself in trouble it might be
appropriate for a study committee on
the term default budget to clarify this
whole paragraph
um but as far as the as far as line 13
goes
um
the default budgets determined by the
select board or the governing body in in
municipalities
um so the issue here would be that
struggle between the the budget
committee and the select board
where the budget committee would now be
determining what may be a reoccurring
expense rather than it being the select
board so
that's the conflict
for the questions
I see none thank you thank you for your
testimony
uh blue sheet one pro one con and with
that we will close the hearing on House
Bill 313.
you have exactly 15 and a half minutes
before lunch I mean for lunch and we
will once again get going in 1 30. Mr
chair may I break in yes you may uh
representative I really appreciate it
lunch is here for all the members of the
municipal and County government
committee because we are celebrating the
retirement of our fabulous administrator
Heather gouley so I need you to sign her
guest book Mr Graves has promised to be
in charge of it there's a little note in
here I'm going to set up sandwiches in
the corner sandwiches and chips
come help yourself soon and
representative Maggiore is going to find
our dessert yes
14 minutes ago yeah
thank you all so much and we'll bring
Heather in and cheer her we sent her
foreign
questions
we already gave the five-minute warning
that is up so we're gonna ask all uh
thank you representative treeleven for
arranging for all that yummy lunch
appreciate it
my pleasure thank you anything for
Heather
okay we're gonna get started here and
open up the hearing on HB for the 403
relative to the authority of Selectmen
and assessors to Abate taxes and we will
call the prime sponsor who's sitting
walking up representative Smith
foreign
thank you Mr chairman and fellow
Representatives
I am here to introduce HB 403 relative
to the authority of Selectmen or
assessors to Abate taxes every one of
you should have received a packet with
written testimony that I'm going to read
from and it also has two abatement
excuse me two amendments that I attached
to it and I'll explain that as we go
when did that packet come I I gave it to
the oh it's coming around now
someone didn't pay why don't you give us
two sections here representative
also did you fill out a ping card yes I
did I also included it with the package
it's my will he was a he would be fought
okay representative Smith continue
thank you again Mr chairman everybody
ready here we go so there's the
background for this bill this may seem
like it's going off topic but you'll
understand as I go along
I am the chair of the Osby Board of
Selectmen Ossipee has repeatedly granted
property tax exemptions to the Ossipee
Masonic Lodge for decades against the
advice of the assessor this practice is
illegal the Masonic Lodge does not
qualify for an exemption the assessor in
the meeting stated that the Selectmen
could Grant a good cause abatement
a motion was made to Grant the property
tax exemption I voted against it the
other two board members voted for it
this was in a public meeting
some residents then filed the grievings
with the Bureau of tax and land appeals
better known as btla and that hearing
was scheduled
the hearing occurred on January 24 2022
after this hearing the Department of
Revenue dra issued a report by Philip
Bodwell dra assessor which defined good
cause to mean assessment and valuation
errors or hardship
the report also stated that good cause
abatements are discouraged and not
recommended to be used to circumvent
another law meaning if an organization
does not qualify for a property tax
exemption
you should not then issue an abatement
the property tax exemption issued to the
Masonic Lodge was overturned by the btla
and an order was issued for the Masonic
laws to pay back taxes
even though dra defined good cause to
mean assessment or evaluation errors or
hardship this is still ambiguous and not
clearly defined this is why my bill
changes good cause to administrative or
clerical errors and poverty as
determined by federal guidelines on
December 31st in the calendar year
preceding April 1st
I also Define that this law cannot be
used to circumvent RSA 72 this pertains
to exemptions this still gives the
municipality the flexibility but clearly
defines the law this makes government
efficient transparent and accountable
the only reason this illegal Masonic
exemption came to the public meeting is
because I insisted not be done in a
non-public meeting on the RSA
91a32c reputational risks such as Tax
Matters this is where unfortunately
these discussions occur outside of the
public view this is corruption clear and
simple there are two core cases that
show how clearly good cause abatements
were abused and overturned town of
Seabrook docket number
26624-120s and the city of Berlin docket
nhma opposes this bill simply because it
diminishes in their view the authority
of the municipalities they represent a
bill should either be opposed or
supported based on the merits of this
bill not who pays membership dues if you
believe in accountability transparency
and a government free of corruption and
nepotism this bill if it becomes law
brings us one step closer to fulfilling
this obligation I just want to add also
I emailed the whole committee because I
didn't want to print out 100 sheets of
paper I have them here for for viewing
is the town of Seabrook case showing how
good cause abatements again ambiguous
and not clearly defined was abused the
Berlin case here that was index clearly
showing how good cause abatements were
abused and I also have the Bodwell
report which lays out the Ossipee case
and how they Define good cause
abatements so in this packet you'll see
two amendments
the original bill was just for
administrative or clerical errors
my mind is always thinking and trying to
figure ways to improve this to cover you
know more various ways to Grant the
abatement so I I included in the second
abatement excuse me the second
um
Second Amendment sounds sounds kind of
oxymoron there but
um I added
to include administrative or clerical
errors and poverty as determined by
federal guidelines on December 31st in
the calendar year preceding April 1st I
got a call from the New Hampshire Timber
Owners Association uh Mr stock stock I
believe who's here to testify he had a
concern if this was going to exclude uh
an abatement on a Timber cut that was
assessed at say ten thousand came in
determined to be eight thousand would
that fall under the definition of
administrative if you look up the
definition of administrative it would
fall under it but for clarity I added
to the bill I'm going to read the whole
thing administrative or clerical errors
assessment or valuation errors and
poverty as determined by federal
guidelines on December 31st and the
calendar year preceding April 1st
this makes it clear makes it accountable
there's no ambiguity there's no back
room deals you're not giving an
abatement to Uncle Henry because he
can't pay his taxes we are
representatives of the taxpayer and this
provides efficiency and transparency for
everyone
thank you representative do we have a
question
representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um under your latest Amendment the zero
one five five H uh who decides there is
a valuation error
so as you know Selectmen are responsible
for almost everything in a municipality
um it's a lot of this is above our pay
grade we hire contract assessors in this
case we use Granite Hill Municipal
Services
he covers 12 municipalities through a
contract Service so he's about a large
company that is his determination to to
bring all the rules and regulation that
the state sets for in assessments to
then advise the board how to vote so
it's up to him to make that
determination
further questions representative priests
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question how many other
communities have abused this privilege
under the state statutes besides
Seabrook and Berlin so like I said these
are the only two that I could discover
but in my testimony these discussions
occur in non-public so the public is not
privy to these discussions meaning they
do not see when these abatements go down
that's the underlying problem here so if
there's clearly defined if you remove
good cause when there are if they just
choose to do it in a non-public I don't
do them in non-public anymore I got away
from it so this is not just the people
need to see our business so but if a
board has a right under that under the
RSA that I decided to choose to do these
abatement discussions or Tax Matters for
reputational risk in a non-public it's
going to be defined as to how they can
grant that abatement and the public is
then protected
thank you you're welcome
further questions
I see none thank you very much
representative I'm sorry representative
I didn't see you raising your hand
thank you sure thank you Mr chair
yes I am so the guy
that you contract with who tells you
what the tax should be
correct
he is capable of making mistakes
clerical errors absolutely a human being
and so would independent contractors
hired by the select board be subject to
this new this amended law and if so
should they not be so outlined so
abatement to ultimately approved by the
board they're presented by the assessor
to the governing body which is the board
of Selectmen so when he makes his
recommendation the board has to either
vote Yes or no so he cannot Grant it
without the approval of the board takes
a vote of the board
follow up I don't believe that was my
question my question is
can an independent contractor be capable
of making a clerical error as is defined
in this law and if so should it not be
stated in this law that this also
I think
I think it does by default because
they're governed by the rules set up for
assessing practices by the ASB the
assessing Standards Board
again they can't if they make an error
I'll just give you an example they
evaluate we get them all the time he
evaluates a house at 390 000. he put he
added at two extra bedrooms which turns
out on an internal site visit it wasn't
there the value now is 370 he recommends
the board to Grant the abatement because
there's an error in the process yes
that's an error and it's able to be
granted by the board of Selectmen who
again ultimately has the say on it
representative Guthrie thank you Mr
chairman thank you for your testimony
and I have to apologize I came they came
in late okay the chairman didn't give us
would this uh stop the selectman from uh
negotiating when somebody uh is selling
their home or
uh uh
way back in taxes to obey taxes
would they no longer be able to
negotiate with somebody who is destitute
and this is what happens
a lot of times the cases I'm a selecting
about it sure it's a destined to kind of
a operation sure how would we handle
somebody like that right historically
we've done it right so
when you say someone's back in taxes No
One by under the law this is another
issue that came around in oshopee where
the board was granting illegal tax
payment plans Beyond a three-year period
you're not allowed to do that if you are
a selectman and doing that I advise that
you stop because it's not legal once
there's three years of unpaid taxes
you're required by law to then deed that
property that's in the low odds black
and white no ambiguity there in the case
of what you're saying that someone's
destitute of hardship I did put poverty
in there and to follow the federal
poverty guidelines and I do have that
printout and I did email to the whole
committee showing exactly what they if I
can find it in my pile here
showing exactly what the federal poverty
guidelines are which is what used by the
New Hampshire uh I forget dhh
on that DHHS somewhere in the state
utilizes this so that would give you
latitude to be able to Grant an
abatement for the poverty situation and
it goes from 100 to 300 above and that
would be up to the discretion of the
board of Selectmen so so it gives you a
lot of latitude as to give that
abatement just trying to find out how
much you're taking away from us that's
all thank you thank you I am I've been
doing this for quite a while and I in my
opinion it takes nothing away but it
brings accountability thank you very
much no problem thank you representative
majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I'm I'm curious
you've offered several amendments you've
clearly done your homework on this and I
appreciate that I'm concerned about as
representative Gilman stated the word
error and I'm wondering if you had
um let me just read it real quick to
I I think by adding originally it was
assessment excuse me administrative or
clerical errors and then I added
assessment or valuation errors and
errors abroad is Broad it could be a
human error it could be
um it usually it is human error when
they do an assessment it's it's up to
the assessor to make a determination he
does his data entry and he goes back and
determines the valuation makes his
computer entry so that would cover a
data entry in a computer or a field
assessment error so I think it's covered
seeing no more hands raised thank you
very much representative Smith thank you
all right
well good afternoon uh and thank you for
the opportunity to testify I'm Jason
stock I'm the executive director of the
New Hampshire Timberland Owners
Association
and we I'm signed in and opposed in
opposition to the bill
um as you heard from the sponsor I I did
give him a call and with respect to
Timber taxes and how Timber taxes are
assessed because there is there are some
judgment calls
when you have Timber attacks and when we
read the bill
um and said all right what is an
administrative or clerical error to us
that sounded more of a kind of a a I'll
call it a mechanical error in in the
calculation a typographical error and we
said you know how would this affect my
ability as a Timberland owner if I have
a Timber Harvest on in town I um in the
particular piece of property was very
difficult to assess or the quality
wasn't of the Timber wasn't that great
the town who gets a assessment range
from the Department of Revenue just
pegged me at the high end of the range
because that's not a clerical error
would that have would that in fact
impact my ability to seek an abatement
and have that conversation with the
select board to say hey wait a minute I
had to build two miles of road to to get
to the back 40. this uh this Timber was
was uh
storm damaged etc etc let's talk about
this this assessment
um and so
and and I am appreciative the the again
this was a conversation that happened
literally about an hour and a half to
two hours ago I raised those concerns
and and the sponsor brought forth uh
Amendment 155 H you've discussed this
already
um regarding the any errors in
assessment or or valuation and so I
think you know having looked at this
sitting here in the audience and having
looked at this and reviewed it I think
that would take care of our kind of our
concern that if I am valued
inappropriately based on what's actually
on the ground I think that would cover
it
um so I think you know in as much as our
concern is addressed in this this
amendment it sounds like there are other
broader questions and I'm not going to
speak to those but I just that's why I
felt compelled to sign in and I
appreciate the opportunity to testify
thank you very much I'm just going to
ask you the question
um
so what I'm hearing is because of the
change in 155h the assessment evaluation
errors uh rectifies your concerns and
then you would you would therefore be in
support of the bill we would correct
this this addresses Our concern we would
not we we would we could we're fine with
the bill with that Amendment like I said
I can't speak to the other broader
concerns that thank you folks are
vetting for the questions representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question you are one group that this
assessment or the evaluation could
affect and you were able to identify
could you
answer how many more such smaller groups
would be or in a guesstimate I'm not
asking you to give you exact but do you
think there are more that are not here
could be affected in a negative way
thank you for your question I think I
think there may be some others I I the
only the only other one that comes
immediately to the top of my mind is I
know there's a gravel tax
um there's also a a means of assessing
gravel I don't know if they would
encounter I'm not real familiar with
that
but that's the only other one that comes
to my mind
um
as in terms of a quote property tax that
further questions I see none thank you
very much for your testimony next we'll
um
thank you for the opportunity of
speaking on this on this bill
my name is Michael Sampson I recently
retired a couple months ago as Town
Administrator for the town of Canaan I'm
speaking I'm personal uh
position
but it's based on 12 years of experience
in the town of canyons the Town
Administrator
I'm speaking in opposition to the bill
and I'll try to give you some reasons
why
I understand that the language is vague
and subject to abuse in terms of for
good cause shown I've understand that
I also understand that it's potentially
possible for a town
to do something behind closed doors
I understand that too
I also understand they really shouldn't
be doing anything behind closed doors
period there has to be a public record
there has to be a public statement of
what happens it has to be available to
all the taxpayers and it should be a
sufficient Clarity so you understand
exactly who what where and how
that's the way the law is supposed to be
working
so let me give you examples of things
that could happen if this law is changed
first of all this law addresses prior
year taxes it isn't just years not just
one year
so is that common in the law no it's not
it's actually this is the only law that
I'm aware of where if there is an error
that occurred or if there was a problem
that occurred or if the taxes went back
two years or three years it's the only
way we could deal with it you can't file
for an abatement under normal
circumstances till the close of a tax
year and then is taken up in the
following year
so if you eliminate
those those possibilities from the as a
result of this change in the law for
prior year taxes your it causes problems
when we're trying to deal with real
world issues so let me give you an
example
five times in the last 12 years we had
people who were elderly
and they didn't know anything about the
tax exemptions for elderly
nobody reached out to him until we
reached out to him and said hey you're
three years behind in your taxes
and with a great deal of weeping and a
great deal of concern these people that
were living in a mobile home and a
quarter acre lot or an old farmhouse the
quarter liquor a quarter acre lot and
the mobile homes assisted 150 000 in the
town of Canaan our our reduction in
value for an 80 year old person is a
hundred thousand dollars
why because it's a lot cheaper to keep
somebody in their own home and give them
a reduction on the appraised value of
so picture it now this person comes in
after three years of not paying the
taxes on a hundred and thirty five
thousand dollar property with a mobile
home
he says I've got to sell the property at
that point that person owes five
thousand dollars and they're living at
about fifteen thousand dollars a year
so what did we do
we said okay here's what we'll do we're
going to put you on
as an exemption eighty thousand dollar
exemption going forward and we
understand that you have no way to pay
those taxes from the past unless you
sell your home
a typical rental for that person today
in the town of Canada
is somewhere between 800 and 1100 a
month
as a cost-effective matter for the town
of Canaan
not to mention the humanitarian issue
that was involved
it made absolute sense to Abate the
taxes for those prior year taxes
and to get them onto that program for
exemption in the future
other things come up that are similar
types of things we have several small
quote non-profits in the community
they pay taxes
4-H
if they have a problem with their taxes
and a particular year remember this is a
volunteer organization it helps kids
with their future lives and it's all
done by people that really care about
kids in the community
and if they can't pay their taxes unless
somebody donates some money then they're
subject to the same three-year rule
and it has come up in the past where
that did happen
and we abated the taxes for a particular
for one year
this language as it was drafted has been
used by our town probably seven or eight
times always in public always on a
public record always with public
discussion
and we've on the divisive Council
believe that that was for good cause the
good cause being the betterment of the
community
the humanitarian need to take care of
people make sure they have housing
without jeopardizing anybody else
except if there's a burden that goes
back to taxpayers as a result of it but
the truth of the matter is the town of
Canaan for the last 12 years that I was
in it whenever this happened we had to
cover those tax revenues so we're lost
for the school for the county for the
state we still had to cover them it made
absolutely no difference to anybody else
didn't make any difference to the school
or the other taxpayers what it did do is
it came out of revenues were available
in an assigned fund balance or reviews
they were left over at the end of the
year in Surplus
so number one
you get rid of this there is no
flexibility
the only thing it could be for those
specific things the examples I gave you
don't qualify under this language or the
amendment
so you get rid of the flexibility number
two
it means that we have to then
reduce our ability to be a Vibrant
Community either with non-profits or for
people staying in their own homes and
being masters of their own fate
so take us up somebody that's making
twelve to fifteen thousand dollars a
year on Social Security
um sir I'm sorry we have about a three
minute time period no I apologize we're
up to about six so if you could kind of
wrap it up please I I hope I've made the
point I think that the language uh good
cause could be improved to say good
costs to the community or for
humanitarian purposes or something like
that but I think it'd be a mistake to
get rid of all the flexibility that's
currently available in the law thank you
any questions representative priests uh
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question as I read the
amendment
it says may and may is different from
Shell and may gives you the flexibility
to take into these accounts the
humanitarian cases that one might see is
that correct
I don't I'm sorry I don't have a copy of
the amendment in front of me but the
question is does the May
right now it's it's may as well
but it may means the selectment you know
my selectment informed me yesterday look
or my chairman of the board reinformed
me yesterday look there's nobody else
closer to the community than the board
of Selectmen in any given town okay I'm
gonna I'll answer representative
priest's question the word may Abate is
there you are correct that is existing
language that is not changing so uh for
everybody on the committee I think
might be helpful to to tell everybody
anything that's in bold is new anything
that is in uh unbold or whatever you
would call it a regular font is is
existing language okay so we have
um the only thing in here and speaking
to some of the points uh
Mr Sampson has made
the only thing in this bill that has
changed is the removal of good cause
shown and then clarifications making it
more specific as to what that might have
met met that's the only change so that's
just for clarification any further
questions
representative save us thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question
um say you don't have the amendment in
front of you
correct if the amendment included the
word poverty as a condition would that
change your view of the bill it wouldn't
and it doesn't uh
the representative is correct the three
levels of non-profit non-poverty it's
100 off 200 300 so it doesn't Define
which one either and you could have
fairly heavy pay uh three three times
poverty level
representative Brown
thank you Mr chairman I guess my
question for you is if it was required
in these instances just to be
mandatory to be done in public hearing
would that satisfy your concerns oh yes
I mean I I think it already requires a
okay thank you
I see none thank you for your testimony
thank you
nature Grace sorry
thank you Mr chair nature craze for the
New Hampshire Municipal Association so
we do oppose this bill
um because I know many of you have have
looked at our policies since I handed
them out
um we
have a policy to support what our what
our members bring forward and so I know
that the town of Ossipee supported this
um and we also have an obligation to
protect local authorities so we weren't
quite sure what to do so we brought that
to our board of directors last Friday
and they instructed us to oppose this
bill
um because it limits Authority and and
the discretion of the select board
um I don't believe I really need to add
anything
um given the last uh speakers
um explanation
um the only thing I I do want to add in
response to a question that
representative Brown asked
um requiring that these abatements occur
in public the only statute Tory
framework that I'm aware that you might
want to look at is the welfare statute
because there is something in there
about protecting the privacy of people
receiving Municipal welfare so you just
want to make sure there's no statutory
conflict if you go that route
have to take any questions thank you
very much Nate uh representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh Mr Grace
in in a
representing your towns and
municipalities
does this in uh in light of local
control versus State Control where does
this fall
taking away local control or giving
local
well obviously there's there's currently
broad local Authority just with the
phrase good cause which is not defined
um and that obviously has caused some
issues in some municipalities
um so
if that were to be restricted that that
would be uh that would be a state
any further questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you whoops and on that we will close the
hearing right after I say the blue sheet
now it's close you can uh send an uh
go online and send us something if you'd
like
okay next up we have House Bill 177
relative to the definition of qualified
structures under
structures under the community
revitalization tax relief incentive
we're slightly behind representative
Hill
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee
my name is representative Pat long
representing Hillsboro District 23 in
the city of Manchester
House Bill 177 was brought a ball
through the discussion with land use
developers attorneys including small
residential owners looking to fill gaps
in the housing market
790 is is tax relief incentive dedicated
to existing structures following a
process enabling municipalities and
developing policy as to how it would
work for them
RSA 79e also requires a review of
potential historical and our cultural
value of the existing structure as it
relates to the municipality
my limited knowledge of 79e is through
serving on the planning board the
Heritage commission and the board of
aldermen Hospital 177 in his attempt in
broadening the scope and its incentives
to all areas of the municipality to
include available land with no
structures on it while maintaining its
historical and cultural discussions
an example
as an example a piece of property in a
neighborhood has a potential for
economic revitalization if RSA 79e can
be considered where currently there's no
consideration although municipalities
could target areas of use I find it
difficult in predicting where those
areas will be until a proposal is
brought to either the zoning and the
planning board in closing House Bill 177
offers an expansions of of incentives
that would benefit both the residents
and the municipality
um in in the city of Manchester we had
an example of a new four-story apartment
unit going up
in a neighborhood with no stores no
businesses no nothing one stat four
tournament apartment went out there was
a barber shop a cultural Barber Shop
um
a small a small Corner Store a small
hardware store so that's one of the
reasons why expanding this would be
beneficial
represent representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative long for taking my
question
um
property the definition of property and
with respect to a tax relief incentive
would you be open to adding the word
deeded property so that it's clear in
the statute should this pass
to whom the tax relief incentive would
go
uh yeah I don't have an issue with that
I mean as an attorney person that's
going to be uh coming up after me he's
more
representative benchputi thank you Mr
Jude thanks uh thank you representative
long for taking my question
how would this benefit with all the tax
exemption and community vitalization tax
how would this address the need of
community in terms of providing housing
or roof over the head for the citizens
of Manchester well thank you for the
question representative I I
currently we have uh the city of
Manchester has 1900 units in the queue
uh residential units uh the residential
units in this 790 which by the way is
enabling it's not a it's not a necessity
it's enabling through the municipalities
uh in the in the downtown area there's
roughly about four uh 12 to 1300 units
going in there and uh this is where the
780 is available and sitting on a
planning board there are ass are there
any affordable housing units coming in
there and the answer is no in the
downtown area you're less apt to get
affordable housing you want market rate
so the answer is no so this would allow
outside of the downtown area
um to expand uh
further questions representative pop
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question is is the the term
property defined anywhere in statute is
there a reference that that
where you're citing and going back to
yeah actually
I mean I can't give you the legal
definition you know my definition is
it's right now it's only addresses uh
structures that are already up uh this
would expand it to land that's available
if there's an abandoned you know if
there's a plot of land somewhere as that
could be used instead of uh just
property that has structures on them and
again uh attorney brison may be more
representative Gilman thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative for taking
my question
um I'm hearing a similar theme that the
word property is um
problematic I guess because I had the
same kind of question and would you be
open to changing it uh sort of along uh
Representatives Davis lines to
um
thank you
oh yeah I forgot what you said yeah I
know I forgotten the words I wanted to
use
um
I'll have to come back to it a lot of
record
any any language change that the
committee after doing your due diligence
you'd want to change it would suffice to
me and can I have a follow-up Mr chair
uh follow up go ahead and the uh the
last thing was
um with this kind of change going from
structures to a generic parcel would we
have to re-adopt the RSA that the
enabling action that first took place
yeah I believe that uh I got a call from
the Hampshire Municipal Association uh
that that would be uh suggested that
municipalities re-adopt the 790 policy
as as it fits them with this new change
thank you
further questions
representative priest
thank you for thank you for allowing me
to question and thank you for taking my
question
um you're very familiar with the city of
Manchester and you probably have an idea
how many new parcels
with this
occur in the city of Manchester
and how many housing proximately housing
units could be built with this tax
incentive yeah thank you for the
question I mean I couldn't guess then
how many I have been approached by the
small landlords uh who says if I do you
know what can you give me if I do this
and it's you know it's a four-story
tenement with a barber shop or a
hardware store or and there is no
incentive I could give them other than
maybe an expedited planning board
process or what have you and that's it
for the questions representative
mangaputi I see you down there
thank you Mr Ted I was wondering but
thank you for indulging thank you
representative long for uh taking my
you have uh that community
revitalization tax relief incentives
have you looked at other incentives like
property assess clean energy
uh investment credit or infrastructure
basically those kind of tax credit and
incentives that is not available
currently but available federally would
that enhance
to build a community that's needed today
not 10 years down below sure yeah I have
thank you for the question I I have
looked at that and it's it is minimal
um it doesn't really push the project
over
you know over the line to go uh but yes
I'd have considered those still
thank you representative
seeing no further questions thank you
next we have John Bisson Beeson
that's where I'm from whenever I'm from
in Lewiston Maine it's Bisal so I
appreciate that
um I'm John Bisson which is what I say
here in New Hampshire I'm an attorney
from Manchester as Mr
representative long said our firm is
actively involved representing
developers landowners and I think some
of the questions that you had you're all
focusing on some really interesting
issues with the statute and the changes
what is being asked is to expand the
community revitalization tax relief
incentive program and I'm here to report
that it is a wildly successful program
as it exists now
what the amendment is suggesting and
proposing is to expand the scope of what
already exists in two ways right now the
statute is geographically Limited
to but by reference to town center and
downtown the existing language says this
program is available at the town center
and downtown in addition it applies as
it exists today only to structures it
does not apply as representative long
suggested to open Parcels of land so the
amendment that's being proposed again
will do two things
it will allow the municipality to use
this incentive program throughout its
Community not limited to the downtown or
the center and if you're familiar with
Manchester you know if you're driving
along Brown Avenue towards Litchfield
you're not in the downtown you're not in
the town center and if there's a
property that doesn't have a building on
it this program wouldn't be available
and so the amendment would would broaden
its reach and and also the relief that
is or the incentive that's being
proposed as it exists now it's really
just a pause right it's a pause on the
increase in the tax
bill that a developer would face and I
think that's important developers in the
example that Mr long talked about you
know if if you have a sort of a
distressed property and you're thinking
I really should invest in it I should
make it more valuable you've got a
double whammy right you're going to put
money in the property and then the
community is going to tax you at a
higher rate
we all appreciate that that's how taxes
work this incentive program gives you a
pause it doesn't forgive you from that
increased tax forever it's for a limited
period of time as an incentive as the
statute was defined I can give you some
really clear specific examples of how
this program has been as I said wildly
successful
73 Hanover Street in Manchester if
you've been there it's right across the
street from the Palace Theater it was an
underused commercial property
on the cusp of becoming kind of an
eyesore because it was vacant and you
couldn't put tenants in there because it
was commercial
so a developer looked at it and said I
can rehabilitate that property
and I I'm trying to make the numbers
work
if I dump a ton of money into it I'm
going to have this increased tax bill
what can you do for me so the developer
is looking at a building built in 1871
45 000 square feet of commercial space
that basically can't be rented
the developer dumps eight million
dollars into the property
adds 43 rental units and retail space on
the on the ground floor in addition it's
going to Spruce the property up we're
gonna have a better entrance a better
exterior it's right there in the center
of Manchester and it's going to bring 43
new apartments to downtown Manchester
part of the the inventory that Mr long
was talking about 379 Elm Street in
Manchester that's right across from
Market Basket on South Elm it's a
beautiful new apartment building that's
going in there it's a 15 million dollar
building and it replaced a vacant
Warehouse the former Goulet Supply
building built in the early 1900s that
was crumbling and vacant
same thing I need help I need incentive
those two properties 133 residential
units in downtown Manchester my favorite
project probably even though I'm not
from the area because I'm from
Manchester the China Mill in Allenstown
if anybody knows it it was a beautiful
Mill when it was built architectural gem
falling apart
an absolute eyesore vacant falling apart
168 000 square feet built in 1870
the developer same idea that we've got
this eyesore I need help 22 million
dollars into that building it's going to
bring 150 Apartments to Allenstown New
Hampshire
not only is it going to bring a 150
Apartments it's going to bring all those
residents within feet of the downtown of
Allenstown I would love to own a copy
Coffee coffee shop on the corner because
you're going to have all these young
people
living there so that's what this
incentive program has done it's wildly
successful those are just three examples
that my small firm in Manchester knows
about if you looked harder and farther
you'd find far far more
um The Limited changes that you're
making will give the municipality the
authority to use this tool
throughout its Community without
Geographic limitation and to include
open space process as well as structures
some of the questions that you had that
I listened to before with respect to the
deed reference and the the definition
situations there are other parts of the
statute that are not being amended here
today that deal with those issues
there's an application process that
needs to go to the community level the
applicant must be the landowner so the
the issue of D did I don't think it's
necessary I don't think it would change
anything but the part of the application
process we have to submit the deed and
all of that other stuff so it deals with
that
I can't
um I can't come up with a reason
based on the success of the program to
Advocate against this it's a very
successful program and it's been used
throughout the state and I would
encourage you to do this amendment
Fair testimony
are there any questions representative
Gallagher
hi so um I have a a question about the
uh
so you split it into two sections one
about location and on the other about
prep property um so
um my questions about the first part as
um someone who considers myself
an urbanist and represents a downtown
district of here here in Concord um I'm
a big fan of
having towns having and cities having
strong downtowns for the all the
benefits that increased density brings
so I'm kind of wondering about these
other designated sections like could you
give us some examples of what these
other designated
sections might be and if this will take
away from downtowns at all
um it's a good question thank you
designated sections would give authority
to your community conquered to create
sections zoning districts Etc where this
relief would be available to encourage
in Manchester for example out by the
airport that's a Zone that's a district
that could be a designated section so if
you look at the language that's being
proposed in the amendment you're adding
to the statement that says to enhance
downtowns and town centers or other
designated sections of a municipality
that's the local Authority deciding
where the tools should be available to
representative stavis
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question
um
pose a hypothetical
that relates to the bill and to the
process and to get to get your expertise
on this
in a um in a municipality West Downtown
West Lebanon New Hampshire you may know
it
there are several properties
that are owned by folks in town that
have
setback rental buildings that are rented
to various tenants at various times but
that have Frontage considerable Frontage
that is completely dilapidated parking
parking lot that no one can park in
grass growing up in the cracks
will this apply to that portion of that
property
that might entice that landowner that
property owner who owns the structure
and is renting it but does not care to
do anything about the vacant lot in
front of it could this be of benefit to
us a city like West Lebanon where that
is very prevalent
it I suppose it could be the issue would
be
the the motivation right for the owner
if they could figure out a way to add
additional rental units by redeveloping
that blighted part of their property
then this incentive program would be
helpful because there's there's in
addition to the location issues of the
statute as amended there's also a
qualifier that says the amount there's
numbers on the amount of the investment
it has to exceed a certain percentage of
the
pre-change value so in your situation
someone would have to look at this part
of their property and say I can add six
units and it's going to cost me two
million dollars and the rest of it works
then they could get the the benefit of
the incentive so it is a tool that may
be available but it goes back to whether
or not the owner can develop the
property in such a way that they can
create more units but simply to to
beautify it this would not work thank
you
representative manager booty thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question I'm looking through the bill
and
um
influence or change RSA 53 the municipal
PACE program I don't see any
I'm I'm sorry what was the second
reference uh the RSA 53 I'm not familiar
off the top of my head what that is that
is part odyssip 53e and F is Municipal
Pace Building I mean
yeah
I'm not sure what it okay thank you
thank you
further questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
thank you Mr chair nature Grace for the
municipal Association we have no
position on this bill I just want to
provide uh information to the committee
um so there are there are two things we
noted when reading through the bill
um there did not appear to be language
about whether re-adoption would be
required or not of the 79e statute I
know that representative Gilman asked
that question and the kind of Corolla
corollary question that we had was
whether this would be retroactive or not
it's obviously a definitional change
79e
zones already exist throughout the state
and we just wanted to have Clarity on
whether that would that would change or
not
and that's all I had
thank you uh questions
representative manage Puti thank you Mr
chair maybe you can answer if there is
further questions
I see none thank you blue sheet one pro
one con close the hearing on House Bill
177 open the house bill
293 allowing the town to appropriate
funds to create Town scholarship
representative Hill
huh
the stage is yours thank you Mr chairman
um
a
appreciate uh being welcome to Municipal
and County
um
I have what I think for you is a very
simple bill but I should introduce
myself I am representative Greg Hill
represent the town of Northfield
I am here to introduce House Bill 293
which I think I would classify as a
housekeeping Bill more than anything
else
um
I should point out uh that I have
um attempted to do this in my local town
and was thwarted in that effort by the
town attorney
um
the uh the selectman requested
information from the town attorney to
find out if um if such a thing a town
scholarship fund would be an appropriate
thing for us to do through a petition
Warren article which is what I filed and
uh and the town attorney
recommended no it would not be
appropriate
and the reason is if you look at RSA 31
colon 19a which is what the bill is
talking about
it says the town May at any annual or
special meeting Grant and vote such sums
of money as it deems necessary to create
trust funds for the maintenance and
operation of the town
and that bold section was not there
and then it says and any other public
purpose that is not foreign to the
town's institution or incompatible with
the objects of its organization
that's what the attorney was pointing to
that that last or
um he said that because the town is a
part of a Cooperative School District
they didn't have a reason to have a town
scholarship
if the town had their own School
District then it would be okay
again attorneys the attorney's words not
mine
um and in fact in conversations with uh
an attorney over at the Attorney
General's office just last week he
pointed out that there are any number of
towns that already have these
scholarship programs and I'm getting
nods uh so they're aware
um but because
a Cooperative School District didn't
have
um
education or scholarship in its
purview
they said that or this attorney said it
was only appropriate if it was
specifically spelled out in the law
this is why I'm here
um so from my standpoint
um just specifically spelling it out by
saying for dedicated scholarship trust
funds exclusively for Town residents
that that satisfies that and that was
the language that I asked the attorney
um what what would be appropriate for me
to put in that that section
um I'm not sure what other information
oh I I should mention to you that the
Attorney General's office had called me
last week to ask about this but only
because he was he wanted to confirm with
me that this money would not be
co-mingled with any uh donated money
that comes to the town for under that's
under the purview of the trustee of the
trust funds
um don't
here's another Oddity for your
edification donated money that comes to
a town is covered under the Attorney
General's purview but money that that is
appropriated to the town is covered
under the dra so he he was just letting
me know that there was no
conflict from his standpoint unless we
co-mingled those funds with donated
money that came to the town
so with that I'm happy to answer any
questions
and try to stay within my three-minute
time limit
you did well representative
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
it's not clear to me from your testimony
exactly where the funds for the
scholarship will come from it will it
will the monies be raised and
appropriated by the municipality to be
placed into the scholarship fund yes
thank you for your question
representative
um
the original
intent and and the reason that the town
attorney got involved in it was that we
had a petition warrant article
um on on the Town Warren asking to raise
an appropriate
and and it was so long ago I don't
remember how much we were doing not that
it matters
um but that was that was what we were
doing was Raising and appropriating at
town meeting
thank you representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question wouldn't such an
um thank you for your question
um I don't think it would be
um I I think this was well I mean I
could see how the argument could be made
um but it was in terms of the
um
town meeting
I'm trying to
scramble here and think how it was
worded at the time but in terms of the
town meeting it was almost as if we were
raising and appropriating
um
uh money for any event that we've done
you know we've we've raised and
appropriated money to send a group to a
convention somewhere or something like
that and I suppose ultimately it does
come from taxation
um
but I just it it wasn't it wasn't
objected to a town meeting for that
purpose
thank you for your question
representative Gallagher
hi um I was just wondering
if we could get some clarification about
what type of scholarships specifically
were talking about here like what level
of school primary secondary
post-secondary or what
thank you for your question
um it's a good question
um
what we were talking about at the time
um but I purposely left it blank
um from from my standpoint this is
enabling legislation that's why it says
may a town May
um I wanted to leave it up to the town
to decide what those scholarships would
would be used for whether they are
being used for post-secondary whether
they are
um
um having the money go
wherever the towns people want it I
truly because we are not a home rule
state and I'm not sure you've had that
phrase yet
um this is this has to be put in there
and allow the towns to be able to do it
um so from my standpoint I was trying to
make it as flexible as possible so the
town would decide what those funds were
to be used for and that's why it says
for a dedicated scholarship trust fund
scholarship can be in a number of areas
so I appreciate that
uh representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
how would this interact with the
education Freedom accounts and can
somebody get both
um thank you for your question I don't
think it has any connection to the
education Freedom account
um so I
um
I would I would say you know if I Were
King yeah you could get both
um but it truly is still up to that town
to create the parameters here so um
you know you don't see
anywhere in here what you can or can't
do they they are doing it this is only
to give them the permission to to
um have a dedicated scholarship fund it
doesn't set the parameters of of what it
can be used for or how it can be used
thank you
representative Holland
so thank you for taking my question Mr
chair
um so I actually represent a Cooperative
district and we have many scholarship
funds all of those scholarships are from
donated money my question is why not
just ask your community please donate
the money why are you using taxpayers
money uh you know which is non-voluntary
as opposed to voluntary with a donation
uh thank you for your question
um
I don't
you know I in an individual Cooperative
School District
um this seemed the easiest way for one
of those towns I I wasn't clear when you
were saying that you
um are coming from the school district
itself or from an individual town but
from my individual Town
um I suppose we could but there would be
nowhere for those dollars to be held
that's the point of this to have those
to have a place for those those dollars
to be held in The Cooperative School
District according to our attorney
can I ask a follow-up you may
couldn't the funds that you raised be
held within the school district itself
they could set up an account and then
the money is donated into that account
under the names of example like if I
live in Durham and voluntarily I asked
Durham residents can you please donate
money to the Durham scholarship fund at
the school board or at the school level
that I could set up an account where
that money is transferred in from those
donation it would still represent it
would still a name be the Durham
scholarship fund but the money is all
donated instead of being taxed yeah I
I'm I'm not aware
um of of whether that is the appropriate
method this was the appropriate method
that my town attorney
asked for
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking an additional question so to be
clear the language in this this bill
line four the scholarship
it does not imply for academic purposes
a scholarship could be awarded for other
purposes other than academic in the
second parts of that question is is
similar with regards to town residents
there is no age limit so I mean the a
scholarship purpose could be for in
sorry to say an infant as well as
somebody that's that's elderly so that
is that a correct interpretation it's
it's wide open with regards to
application and the age of the Town
resident thank you for your question
um
representative Andrew
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
if the scholarship fund is established
exclusively for Town residents
and there is a public school
or ready existing there
how would it
take the tax education tax funds
from the existing public schools into
this would would that take the money
away from the public school education
fund into this
scholarship fund no I don't believe it
would
representative service
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question yet another question
um
is there meant to be any means testing
for this scholarship fund I mean could
it go to somebody attending Harvard
Business School could it go to somebody
attending local trade school what what
is the scope
of what you're proposing here can
somebody earning 5 million dollars a
year be eligible
I think the answer is yes
um the the answer is as I've said
um several times here
um this is this is open to the town and
the town's people to decide what that
scholarship money is for all I'm doing
is creating the place for it to be put I
I'm not I'm not creating parameters I'm
not creating that's that's the towns
people need to do that is the way I look
at it
representative priest
thank you Mr chairman uh and thank you
for taking my question yes since the
town is going to be paying into this
scholarship fund
well they have the opportunity to decide
who gets the scholarship
again uh thank you very much for your
question
um
I would say where I doing this in my
town that those parameters would be
discussed
um in
prior to this going into effect
um it would be obviously there's nothing
in here that says who is managing this
fund who all of those items including
your question would be something that
the town would decide for themselves
and and that's all that this is doing is
creating that authorization for them to
have that account that's all it's doing
uh representative Hicks thank you Mr
chairman Mr representative Hill so a
town may never utilize this is that
further questions
I see none thank you very much
representative Hill thank you I have one
thank you Mr chair uh again we have no
position on this bill
um there's only one thing that the
committee hasn't covered yet that I
wanted to mention which was that
um uh as written if if this is a warrant
article that creates a trust fund I
believe it's the case that you'd either
need to have agents to expend listed in
order to you know authorize somebody to
hand out these funds or you'd have to
have a town meeting vote in order to
authorize the expenditure
um so you know if I was if I was your
town resident eligible to to go to
college you wanted to give me a
scholarship you'd either have to vote a
town meeting to authorize that
specifically to be paid out to me or you
would have to have previously
um
authorize some specific you know the
select board or somebody to to set up a
system whereby they'd pick whoever could
you know be the award recipients for
this year so that's the only information
I want to provide the committee
thank you further questions
representative priests thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question shouldn't there be a sunset
um
provision in this bill that says These
funds have to be used by a certain date
five years
so they just don't go so trust funds
don't have a sunset provision they just
last forever so your municipality may
have some trust funds from 100 years ago
particularly in your Cemetery side of
things
okay and those would be the quests
normally
for the questions
I see none but I have one that I
actually should ask to representative it
just hit me
um it was mentioned that
we know this is simply a vehicle to
allow a town to do it if they should
choose but many towns probably won't do
it do we have an idea the number of
towns that actually already have this in
place I'm assuming non-cooperative
school districts so about what your town
would probably already have in place is
a bequest
um and I think there's a
the charitable trust Foundation our
charitable trust division of the ages
office told me about one it was down in
Peterborough or something like that from
about 100 years ago where someone had
set up a I believe it was a trust for
upon their death a trust for
uh residents school kids of the Town who
were Protestants or something and they
go through a whole process because you
can't restrict based on religion
um to to do that so I'm not aware of any
towns that would have an existing trust
fund created by taxpayer dollars via the
war article process it's possible one
exists but I'm not aware of one
um
I do know that there are towns that hold
trust funds for educational purposes
that are the quests that basically were
set up by somebody who was wealthy who
then passed away or decided to give the
town this money and they they run that
that trust but that's something the AG's
office could answer better than I could
okay thank you very much
we had one sign in on the blue sheet in
favor and that was all on that we'll
close the hearing on HB 293 we are past
230 so we will go ahead and open up the
next hearing HB 294 enabling
municipalities to adopt a child tax
credits
and I do understand that representative
Simon is out of town
I assume I am looking at representative
Rocher yes very good thank you
thank you Mr chairman uh Madam Vice
chair members of the committee uh my
name is David rochever I am from
Littleton and I represent Grafton one
and uh this is my first term here
and I serve on the Ways and Means
Committee
and
before I get too far into this bill I I
just
and share with you what our days are
like and they're not like this uh we we
listen to a lot of reports a lot of
projections
um you know some of it can be Doom and
Gloom some of it can be exciting and uh
make us feel like we have a lot of money
in the bank
one of the things that I'm sure you all
are aware of I know you're aware of but
that has been
emphasized over and over and over again
for the last three weeks and our
committee is our aging population
and it's it's it's to the point where
New Hampshire's population is aging uh
almost fastest only second domain in the
state in the country so what that looks
like as a grander scale in our state
is we look at some of the jobs that we
have that need to be filled we've got
literally thousands of jobs that are
unfilled right now in the state of New
Hampshire and the three sectors that
those are primarily located in are
Health Care Service
and restaurants in retail you could mix
those in there as well so these are all
areas that are General these are jobs
that are generally filled by younger
people
so this bill HB 294
go back a little bit we as a body we
have to start getting creative uh within
what we're doing here in the state of
New Hampshire uh it's an imperative that
we get creative because our our
population even in the last 10 years
you're ending in 2020 our our young our
youth population went down by 10 percent
so we have to start thinking out of the
box we have to start thinking of
different ways that maybe have not been
addressed here in the state of New
Hampshire and that's what HB 294 looks
at this is like the last bill we heard
of this is an enabling piece of
legislation being that New Hampshire Is
Not a Home State uh State the
municipalities have to get permission
from here to do anything that that may
be thinking outside of the box so what
HB 294 does like I said it's an enabling
piece piece of legislation it doesn't
Force municipalities to do anything
there's no
um Demand on them but if they so choose
if the voters of a municipality so so
choose to enact a
child tax credit
they can do that in their state and the
point of that would be is to attract
people younger people into the community
some communities you know Senate are
representative Simon and I concede that
they may not ever
consider it based on the demographics of
their computer Community uh the finances
of their Community but other communities
this might fit very well but the point
here today is to ask to get this bill so
they can at least have that choice and
make that choice on their own
um
if you look at the second part of the
bill the first part of the bill
addresses the tax credit for property
owners with children the second part of
the bill uh enables the municipality to
extend those tax credits to landlords as
an incentive to rent to families with
children so we feel that by doing that
you're you're being you give these
municipalities a potential to
bring younger people into various types
of housing situations
um this idea of a carve out tax credit
for various segments of the population
is not new in New Hampshire uh we
currently do it for veterans we do it
for elderly so we're not we're not doing
something radical here uh with this bill
um
and the other thing is that
we feel like again I mentioned this way
open is by getting these at these
younger folks in there we can start
filling those jobs and and adding to the
success and stability of our of our
state overall so that's the that's the
outline of the bill again it's nothing
we we've done this before with other
segments uh it's not something that's
forced on the municipalities but by
doing this here we give them the option
to think outside the box to be creative
and work work to try to get some younger
folks moving in moving into New
Hampshire
um
like I said
representative Simon is the primary
sponsor he's out of town today I'm happy
to answer questions but if if we get
into something I don't know I'm gonna
I'm gonna ask him to to follow up with
you directly but I'd be happy to answer
any questions you might have
thank you for your testimony
Representatives Davis
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
the other tax exemptions that you
mentioned for the elderly for veterans
are means tested I don't see any means
testing in this bill and again the IDE
the cons or did I cut you off I'm sorry
I apologize
um hold that thought
um so I don't see any means testing
which means that I could be
um
a landlord that owns 25 duplexes uh and
I could say that I'm renting to families
with children but I am not I I'm not
forced by any law that's stated here to
pass that credit through to
the renters it would come to me as the
landlord so how do we Square no means
testing no enforcement mechanism to make
sure that the the target is
that's being aimed for is actually being
hit yeah
so and and how and who pays I'm sorry
who pays the question first and then all
right I'll follow up all right so to
answer your question about the means
testing so that that is a that's an
excellent question and and we we just
representative Simon and I were just
talking about that this morning you know
how do we uh you know would that be an
issue and first of all the guidelines of
the tax credit would be left to the
municipalities so that would be up to
them to develop the criteria under which
this is passed on secondly one of the
one of the conversations that we had was
that um
or the concerns is that you know it is
not passed on to the tax credit but what
we found in the research that that
senators or representative Simon has has
done is that the rent the rents that
people pay are paying in in New
Hampshire are largely
the closing back to well if you give a
tax credit is that passed on to the in
to the renter and what his research has
has found and I'd be happy to have him
follow up to give the sources of the
research on that but uh is that the
renters or excuse me the rent in New
Hampshire is largely based on demand and
and it's less based on
um property taxes for instance so for
instance in Massachusetts
uh we have
comparing Massachusetts in in New
Hampshire the the property tax rate in
New Hampshire is much higher than in
Massachusetts but in Massachusetts
equalized it's a much higher the rent is
much higher so the the the concept is
the rent is largely based on demand and
that this tax credit would then
um it would indirect as I understand it
it would indirectly
affect the not not direct the the the
landlord is ultimately the one that's
going to
um benefit from the tax credit
because they're the ones that are
opening up their properties to allow
younger people in there which oftentimes
landlords are reluctant to open those
properties up to younger people because
of fear of damage decreased property
value
Etc
and I know that was a long answer to a
short question and uh and and I'd be
happy to if if that doesn't answer I'd
follow up thank you
hey Mr chair
so
this goes to effect
towns B and C adopt it
who in those towns pays for the credits
that go to the child tax credit who does
that burden fall on so ultimately so for
instance I can speak in in our town when
we have an elderly tax credit or a
veteran tax credit it's the people of
the town that pay for it
so they're the ones that are going to be
voting to actually
put this in place so there you know it's
it's not going to be there's gonna the
town will decide whether they want to
implement something like this so they're
making the decision whether they want to
representative Guthrie
thank you and thank you for taking my
question I'm so sorry that we're so late
in the day we just could take a long
time uh I have two questions really the
first one is uh what is a
independent a dependent minor child what
is there a description for that is it an
age thing or what is it I don't know if
it's defined somewhere else in law but I
I it you know it's it would refer back
to a dependent I I imagine it would
refer back to tax code that defines
dependent child where a child can be
declaimed as a dependent follow-up Mr
chairman uh follow up so
uh as we do in the elderly could you
could we uh say that uh it would put a
we could put a age criteria and is it
possible that the program should require
that we'd only give this tax relief
until the child
is in our school system because we pay
for them once they get in the school
system in you know in the not directly
but we're paying for them when they're
in the school system would it make some
sense to have the program last until the
person that the child goes to school so
you're saying so it depend if I could
under just to understand the question
it's the way it's written now let me
stop you for a second yeah I think we
have somebody who's probably going to
test somebody that can probably get a
little bit more specific it tends to
fall into more of a okay I have no
problem waiting yeah thank you I think
he'd be able to answer it a little bit
better uh representative of Manchester
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
um if I understand the bill correctly it
says the tax credit is either given to
the landlord to encourage
renters with young children or young
families to come in
or
young families to buy so that they get
what tells us that I could be a landlord
take the credit
but I may choose who which young family
that I can rent it to
there is no stipulation of how you could
do it so we want to encourage young
families youngsters I agree
but
is there a way that this will be more
inclusive representative is there a
question yes that's where I was ending
uh thank you Mr chair is is there any
incentive to include diversity inclusion
irrespective
of the
families coming in for renting
yes thank you for your question I I
think that you know what you bring up is
is
a valid and a timely issue the intent of
the bill I think is it doesn't go that
far uh the the Bill's intent really is
to allow municipalities to do this it
doesn't get into the granularity of
defining you know of that so so to
answer your question I think that
decision would largely be left up to if
the bill passes as is it would be
largely be left up to the municipalities
who either choose or don't choose to to
put this type of tax credit into into
place
representative yokella
thank you thank you for uh taking the
question
um talking to constituents it's it's the
um empty nesters and the elderly that
wish to have attacks break because they
aren't the ones causing the the high
high school taxes
um so I'm just wondering uh no one uh
that I've ever come in contact with
while I was what while I was uh
representative you Keller is there a
question yes thank you
um no one I've that I've ever come in
contact with has asked you know for
um tax break for the people that are
used utilizing the school system which
cause 80 of the taxes
what are what were the reasons or how
many people I guess came to you to ask
for this to be like that they needed
that this uh law to be passed so that
they could Institute this or is this
just
another way of trying to uh get young
people into the community yeah so thank
you for your question
um
representative Simon is the primary
sponsors that he'd probably have the the
specifics on that I signed on as a
co-sponsor of more uh of a general
concept idea of this you know
um personally I I thought this was a
unique and and and engine
ingenious type of thinking in order to
attract younger people personally that
you know as far as how he got to the
point of putting this to paper you'd
have to ask him you know where that but
that's that's the background why I
supported that
thank you representative Gallagher
um so
in 2021
the federal government
expanded its own tax credit I think it
was as part of one of the covid relief
packages or something
um
which
was in fact in effect for about a year
until
it expired and failed to be renewed
um just due to disagreement so I was
wondering
um
if
you looked into how the
debate over the federal child tax credit
laid out in the last few years when
studying this uh Bill and how that might
have informed it and if you could
compare and contrast
um this bill with the federal child tax
credit
yet thank you this bill is really it's a
little different than the federal
child tax credit and that this is a New
Hampshire Centric bill this is a this is
a a bill that would be unique to New
Hampshire and it's actually a
municipality-centric bill so the point
of this bill uh is really more to
attract people in and get young people
into New Hampshire into certain towns
rather than give a break for you know
just a break for anybody that has a
child it's really to incentivize folks
to come to come to New Hampshire and uh
and and if the municipality chooses to
excuse me
I'm curious was there a fiscal analysis
done on this to see how much this would
so again the the point of the bill the
objective of the bill is because we're
like Dylan's law not a home state I
realize that exactly you know the whole
concept was really to let the state give
the authorization for the municipalities
to do this I would imagine if a
municipality decides to go down that
road I know in my in my town we would
you know if we did that there would be a
lot of scrutiny on the financial uh
implications of that but on a on a
global level here because we don't know
which states which towns would do it
Which towns wouldn't do it
we concede the fact that there may be no
Towns at all that take advantage of this
if we pass this
um but uh so so
to answer your question no there was not
a financial analysis done but I imagine
prior to adopting something like this
the municipality that's that's debating
are the questions I see representative
Gilman
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
I'm going to ask the same one I asked
before how will this work with education
Freedom accounts or is that a decision
for the community to make because this
is enabling again this is a 60 000 foot
view a bill which is just the enabling
of that when it get when you drill down
into the granularity of
functionality policy where the money's
going is it financially viable that
would be a decision for the
municipalities to make thank
you thank you representative Powell
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question in your bill
introduction you cited that the bill
would serve as an incentive for land law
Lords to rent to families with children
do you have any concerns that perhaps
maybe if this bill were to become law
and municipalities did in fact adopt it
that it would create a problem for
families without children say elderly to
be able to
have access or the ability to rent due
to this incentive
for landlords to rent to families with
children
so so if I understand your question
right the concern is if this becomes law
we'd be essentially bringing in
displacing elderly because there'd be so
many children come younger families is
that is that the so that's uh
I I don't think that that was a couldn't
I I can say that that personally that
wasn't a concern because that's so far
from where we are right now uh we'd have
to really change wholesome makes
wholesale changes to the demographic of
our state and the trends of our state to
get to that point so
you know speaking for myself that's not
representative Holland
thank you for taking my question
um so uh in New Hampshire the majority
of school funding is paid for by local
property tax and I always had a hard
time believing that but the majority of
our residents actually don't have kids
in school and so therefore the residents
that don't have kids in school are
currently subsidizing the families that
have kids in our school so for example
like Oyster River it's twenty thousand
dollars to pay for a student the state
I'll be generous puts in maybe seven or
eight thousand the majority of that is
coming out to our residents so in other
words this is almost like double dipping
uh do you have concern that this would
cause a backlash that would then affect
the ability to pass your school budgets
so
when we originally were talking about
this bill that was a topic exact topic
that we we brought up and and I think
that the way I rationalize this and the
way I I came to having a a comfort level
was this is the communities are going to
be their own safety valve you you know
the communities will have to vote to
adopt this so
I I know for fact I represent six
communities and not all six would ever
choose to go down this road for that
exact reason uh uh and and that's really
you know the people and their vote and
their town meeting process and uh and
and that debate is really where I came
to understand that's our safety valve
you know I don't think that that uh
um you know in kind of poking holes in
this that was one of the holes that I
found but again I think because the
people this is this is not coming from
the state telling them you have to do it
these are the communities who know their
budgets who know the the school
populations who know and they're going
to be the ones that are voting on it so
um
that's how I came to feel more
comfortable with that that would not
happen because the communities where
that's where there's a potential for
that won't won't go down that road with
this
representative yokella
thank you thank you for taking that
question
um
a lot of opposition at the local level
to development especially for for uh
Apartments is that it's going to
overload the schools and it's going to
be very expensive you know per person
do you see any disconnect for the
increasing of our housing issue with um
if you if this was to pass the there
would be even a there would be an
incentive for the landlord to seek out
those
um younger people with kids so that that
they could get the incentive and from
the municipalities perspective they
don't want to have additional housing
because the fear that there's going to
be more people in school and so
do you see this as a as a potential uh
one of the negative drawbacks would be
that there would be reduced
um housing
um you know development because of of
that kind of Disconnect of incentives
so uh and I the way I just make sure I
understood your question because I think
the question that you're the that you're
posing is a common concern when you give
housing increase housing of younger
people and if I totally missed it let me
know I'm not going to be offended by
that but the way I understood it was
that uh
um by bringing in younger populations
and maybe to multi-family units you're
going to put a burden on the schools in
in was that and you're going to hurt the
school budgets with younger
can I can clarify if you yeah that was
it thank you um I uh I was saying that
the that when someone is trying to
develop something the municipality is
concerned of how that development is
going to impact the school population
and aka the school budget and from the
developer standpoint they want to have
those those people in there because then
they could get this tax credit if this
was to pass so that's kind of differing
incentives absolutely so that's a common
concern I've heard that a lot you know
just in my town right now I know there's
a project that hasn't been announced
publicly but it'll be a hundred units
coming to town and even in in the
conversations that I've had or well geez
that's going to flood the schools you
know we're gonna you're gonna crush the
schools but here's why that logic is
maybe a little flawed actually in fact
the New Hampshire realtors association
did a study on this with UNH and they
found that even though it kind of makes
sense you're putting all these kids into
the schools and actually I would
encourage you to to go on to go to the
New Hampshire realtors association and
see it they've got a they've got a uh
they've got a video presentation of the
findings of the result the the the
reason what they're fine what they found
why that is and this is contrary to what
I personally have had always thought but
now you think of it there are fixed
costs with schools that are never going
to go away you still have to have the
building there you still have to heat it
you still have to have the teachers
there so there's a certain level of
overhead that regardless of how many
students you have in a school is going
to remain constant yeah you may have to
have some specials you may have to have
some more you know some some some
special ad
um but the the increase in the school
population and again this is done by the
this is the the findings of the New
Hampshire Realtor Association is not
directly proportionate to the amount
that you spend on education so yeah that
is a common that is a common objection
when you look at these types of
developments but I think as we've
started to look into those a little bit
some of those
concerns that even myself held at one
time
are proving to be uh wrong because the
reality is we're in again in my
community we're still Staffing at a
level that we were 10 years ago and
there's five to ten percent less kids in
the school so we still have a capacity
of five to ten percent to bring it up to
what it was 10 years ago and and then
there's a lot of overhead costs that
remain the same that regardless if you
put in 10 15 more kids again I've live
in a small town it's not going to change
the overall cost of the school so
um I would encourage you know anyone
who's interested in this that was a
fascinating uh presentation is done by
the New Hampshire realtors association
with UNH and they have it posted on
their website but um thank you very much
further questions we have four more
individuals that we need to get going on
here seeing none
oh it has to be red that's
counterintuitive this is uh this is not
cornerstone's first time in front of
this committee but this is my first time
in front of this committee I'm general
counsel at Cornerstone which is a
Christian advocacy organization and that
is of course the driving reason that we
support any pronatal pro-family policy
but we think that as representative
roachford somewhat outlined even people
that don't share particularly our views
of the family should be concerned about
the demographic situation in New
Hampshire representative roachford
mentioned that we are the second most
elderly state in the country after Maine
we're also the second fastest aging
State and really on any important metric
of demographic health that you can look
at we are either the worst off state in
the country or we're in the bottom three
so for example we've also had the
largest single largest 10-year decrease
in Children of any state in the United
States and for the children who do stay
and are raised in New Hampshire we have
the single highest rate of students who
leave the state graduating high school
seniors who leave the state and a
majority of those never return then when
you look at the the 20 to 40 year olds
my demographic who are in New Hampshire
a third of them say that they are likely
to leave the state and only 19 percent
of 20 to 40 year olds say they feel
committed to remaining in the state so
obviously this is completely
unsustainable which is why as
representative Rochford said we need to
think of innovative solutions
um and really ultimately the people who
are going to be the most harmed by this
demographic trend in New Hampshire are
the elderly and to illustrate that point
in less than 10 years Carroll County in
New Hampshire is going to have a
majority over 65 population and to
emphasize how alarming and how important
that should be there is currently only
one uh documented majority over 65
County in America and it's Sumter County
Florida West of Orlando and it's a
disaster on paper it looks economically
well off the money is there the job
openings are there but the job openings
including for essential services are
flat out not being filled and so people
that have cardiac arrests for example
can wait for an hour and 20 minutes for
an ambulance to arrive one reason we
think a bill like this would be an
appropriate part of the solution and a
step in the right direction is that our
demographic crisis in New Hampshire is
really government created we've had
Decades of New Hampshire policy and
especially policy in communities really
designed to make to depress the number
of young families in New Hampshire
in the belief that we would say is
completely mistaken that that will
decrease school taxes
um I agree with representative yokella
of course the school taxes are the main
driver of taxes in general where we
might have a difference of understanding
as we would say enrollment in schools is
not what's driving those school taxes um
and you know we've seen for example in
communities that have really tried to
depress the number of young families
Pelham until a couple of years ago they
were trying to keep the number of young
families as low as possible what was
happening was that the cost to services
in incurred by residents of
age-restricted housing actually exceeded
the property taxes on the age-restricted
housing units because of our our
one-sided elderly tax abatement that we
have and then meanwhile of course the
school enrollment was going down School
enrollments are going down everywhere
but I think we can all kind of see that
school enrollment is not the driver of
school taxes because school taxes are of
course still going up
so uh we hope that this will be a step
in the right direction and we hope that
it will continue to get some bipartisan
support
um you know on the one hand this would
fix a bias built into our state law in
terms of what municipalities can do
against younger families it would
increase local Choice increase
competition and of course it's an
abatement on your own taxes and then on
the other hand as representative
Gallagher mentioned there was the
expanded federal child tax credit which
was not renewed in the most recent
Omnibus Bill and that was principally a
democratic priority although it had some
bipartisan support and and one
interesting thing I'll note in closing
on that expanded child tax credit at the
federal level is the research is now
very conclusive that unlike some of the
other covid relief that we saw the
federal expanded child tax credit did
not decrease labor participation at all
it just reduced poverty I'd be happy to
take any questions I have spoken with
the the prime sponsor about this
legislation representative Simon who's
unavailable and I I can do my best to
answer some legal questions as well
we're gonna do you have you you didn't
have your mic on so I would I didn't
know if you would just hand your hand
got three no I'm okay
that I had operated on Mr chamber not
this one thing
thank you and thank you for taking our
questions we're kind of in a little
silly this time of day
um we it's been said earlier that uh you
know about the elderly and I happen to
be in that category uh and what we do
for the elderly and you know and I think
that's well taken but I think we could
would you believe that it's possible or
would they would you consider uh in this
bill a the taking that as a a way of a
speech to go down by uh limiting the
amount of Maintenance that would make it
more compatible for the townspeople if
you'd if you had it at fifty thousand
dollars until instead of you know five
hundred thousand dollars and if you put
a limited limit on the cage the age of
the the child that's why I asked earlier
what is a dependent minor uh if we
limited that to one to from them one
year old to when they go to school
because when they go to school we pick
up the you know we I'm talking about
selling it and then uh well then if you
had how about three questions at a time
representative
let's say let's go with those first my
question really is with all the irsas in
this
bill could we take that direction in
setting this up as a community
I'm glad you asked that I have spoken to
representative Simon about that I I
should say at the outset the current
Provisions are modeled on RSA 7239b and
some related rsas in the elderly tax
credit the elderly tax credit gives
municipalities pretty broad authority to
determine what the the dollar amount per
credit would be and so I know
representative Simon wanted to just
start with designating as Broad and
Authority as possible to municipalities
to make decisions in terms of what's
appropriate for them but he has told me
he would certainly be open to if the
committee saw fit at to build in some
more constraints
um and you know parameters on the scope
of the bill that he would be open to
that and certainly From cornerstone's
perspective as long as as the bill is
significantly pronatal and is an
incentive kind of pushing in this
direction an incentive to attract and
retain younger families we we would
probably look positively on the kinds of
parameters that that you mentioned if
there was an appetite for that a quick
follow-up Mr chairman if I could it's
just is
if I can let's let's go um what I'm
going to do I want to have a little bit
of discussion at the end of today but uh
let's um
if your follow-up is truly a follow-up
yes what we've been tending to do here
is asking multiple questions of
different questions and I would prefer
to have each individual ask a question
and then tell everybody else has spoken
um then we can go back if it's a true
follow-up yes you may follow up yeah
thank you Mr chairman it's a yes and no
answer is representative Simon uh a
receptive to putting this in a study
committee where we could the bill could
be more comprehensive
I I expect his answer to that would be
no but I haven't asked him that question
specifically
representative
thank you and thank you for taking my
question should you please define for me
the term pronatal
oh sure just uh encouragement of
children basically is pronatal natal
means birth though
representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question you said in your
testimony uh this would if this bill
passed it would help with competition I
don't understand that can you define
that
sure what I meant there was competition
between municipalities
um you know we we just heard a lot about
how municipalities would sort of be
under some pressure to set the
parameters most appropriate for them and
so we could sort of have a Marketplace
of ideas in terms of how municipalities
go about trying to attract younger
families uh and we we have seen multiple
communities in the last couple years in
New Hampshire trying different things in
order in an attempt to attract younger
families I mentioned Pelham a moment ago
they have now actually got so bad there
they've prohibited new age-restricted
housing so these are uh the kinds of
things that some communities are trying
to do and the idea here is to expand the
options that they have and then let
communities compete amongst themselves
to a degree to find out what strategies
representative Gallagher
hi um so I'd just like to follow up
um about your mention of the
debate over the federal expanded federal
trial tax credit uh so did
Cornerstone New Hampshire
uh take a position on that policy while
the debate was still happening or is
this just something that you've realized
was good now retrospectively
you're talking about the federal
expansion of the child tax credit we
don't take positions on any federal
um issues so no no federal legislation
have we to ever to my knowledge have we
ever taken a position on
um but you know we we think there are
constructive aspects of the federal per
child tax credit and I I am aware that
that the existence of that program some
is something that played into the
creation of this bill at the outset okay
thanks
further questions
seeing none thank you Ian thank you
I'd like to call now uh
good afternoon
this is my first time in any situation
like this so please forgive me
um before you get going
um pull that mic closer to you so he can
hear you really well
and then also before you start please
let us know if you're for or against the
bill yeah my name is Angel I'm for the
bill
um I am a homeowner as well as a um
Homeowner of multi-family as well as a
uh a parent of three young ones which is
where my wife is now she's gonna come
testify but
um yeah I think the I think the bill is
a great incentive point for families
um to come into the state
um for a multi multiple reasons for one
as a um as a man with
um with a family who owns a home and
whatnot we um it's it's difficult to try
to own a home in the first place
um especially what we talked about as
far as like the high taxes and stuff
like that I'm from Massachusetts so I
was blown away when I came up here for
the uh and I saw the tax rates and
whatnot but so it's it's that's a great
incentive in and of itself that it could
provide that relief for families
um as well as
um as a landlord
um
I heard it said earlier today um earlier
in the meeting and it's this place of
like when you're thinking about renting
your own home and your own property that
you're then therefore gonna have to fix
thinking about renting to people with
children especially young children is a
absolute nightmare
um so this this can also provide much
um
uh just leeway and almost security and
what uh in a sense for for landlords as
well to rent to young families
um
especially once you start getting into
you know higher numbers of families and
stuff like that a higher numbers of
children in families
um you know to find housing for anything
more than a two bedroom is extremely
difficult to find housing more than
three bedrooms is even more difficult
you know
um so just for as far as like a rental
or looking for renters for people who
can't afford
um to go into a home I think it's a
great incentive for landlords to think
about you know instead of bringing it to
an Airbnb or you know sell or short-term
rental
um I just think it's a great incentive
thank you for your testimony
representative Rosales
thank you Angel for uh your testimony
here today I congratulate you for being
here and doing such a good job uh I'm of
the belief that are there are people
like you that are the future of New
Hampshire and I would hope that you
would agree with me that whenever a
state or a municipality loses its young
kids
that state or that municipality is
liable to die
I have seen that in my history and I I
think I'm a an old disabled veteran I
get tax abatements out the in-gang so
many that I don't deserve but I take
them I don't need them but there are
people like you that the question is do
you agree with me that we need
abatements like that for young people
absolutely absolutely that was great
well said as well um but yeah absolutely
you know they it's said by many and many
people that a uh the future of a
generation is its young people if there
is no young people then there is no
future
thank you
just for the record representative
only because you rarely speak did I not
oh thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here today isn't it true we've
heard some testimony today about not
wanting to rent two families or children
but isn't it true that's illegal
I guess I actually don't specifically
know I'm not the Fair Housing Act made
that label but I could be wrong thank
you representative priest
thank you Mr chairman for taking my
question and thank you for being here
angel you're from Massachusetts
um you've been I'm sorry
um
do you think other young families like
yourself will move here
to take jobs in healthcare restaurants
and Retail knowing that our wage level
is so much lower than anybody else
I'm sorry I was I just I didn't hear
that last part knowing that our Witch
level is wage levels
are so much lower than anybody else in
the region before they witness please do
not answer that we try to maintain our
questions representative priests to the
subject at hand and this is a child tax
credit not a wage wage debates are
usually in Labor uh Mr chairman I agree
with you that this is a tax credit but
we've been hearing about how this has
been this will be an incentive to bring
in young people to the state with
children and I'm just saying why would
they want to move here and take a
minimum wage that thank you that's a
nice statement but we will move on to
the next question anybody representative
Gallagher
um so you mentioned being both a
landlord and a parent so
um
that kind of made me realize so
um with the two separate
portions
of this bill the one
for the parents themselves and then the
one for the landlords
could you possibly
qualify for both of it like what if you
just rented to yourself or to your
spouse or something or would that let
you
get both of them or what
yeah I mean I would I would imagine that
that has to do with many many loopholes
and trying to you know finagle something
that ought not to be finagled I think
was the open-endedness of this bill that
is a
um parameter that the municipality can
bring up and appropriate for their um
for their Community
um
I guess if it stays as is in every
municipality ordered it exactly as the
bill is written I guess sure maybe
um but I think even at that as one who
has both
um
I mean to try to rent to my wife I mean
that's that seems pretty illegal in and
of itself so
bro
just a quick question uh thanks for your
testimony
um so you've already moved here you
already have children you already have a
house that's great I appreciate you
coming to New Hampshire would this bill
be an incentive for your friends from
Massachusetts someplace else to move
here and make the state their home do
you think thank you absolutely
um per would have per word of mouth I
think the one of the biggest questions
because I'm actually huge since I moved
here I'm like man I could never go back
I'm from the inner city so like I can
never go back to those places
um
but one of my biggest conversations with
Massachusetts homeowners is the tax
rates and I think and majority of my
friends are around my age starting to
have families and stuff like that so
personally outside of like the much more
settled
um quiet living
um like I said the taxes is probably the
other biggest thing that the
conversation comes up and if there are
further and more incentives to actually
say hey actually there's these
incentives you're having kids now
there's actually opportunity for you
save back on those taxes I think it's a
representative save us
Massachusetts already have a child tax
credit that I'm not sure I did not own a
home when I was there
it does so for those I think there are
four seconds
yeah
I guess it's a follow-up I so I guess
there are four states right now that
offer child tax credits so the question
is
do you see
people in other states finding New
Hampshire attractive because it will
join the list
of such States or is it attractive for
other reasons
uh no I think it's definitely attractive
for other reasons but is deterred for
other reasons and I think one of the
biggest deterrents is the high tax rates
so if there are abilities to lessen that
deterrent I think it could provide
something awesome
representative
thank you Mr chair thank you Angel for
coming and participating in the public
hearing my question to you is
congratulations owning the home and
moving from Massachusetts
but don't you believe or do you believe
that your property value
the same house you put it across the
border
will be doubled or tripled
and so the property tax in that sense
this is the only tax that New Hampshire
has so
that in itself is an incentive for
moving up here you get a property that's
in a good
for much lower value compared to
Massachusetts but also this adding this
incentive tax credit if there is a
public school a vibrant public school
education and a community the young
families come anyways
isn't it so is this an additional thing
or would it
so if I may clarify the question if I
think from what I hear you saying is the
property taxes in Massachusetts are
typically higher because the value of
the house is higher so therefore this
property the tax credit wouldn't
actually be doing anything because
you're going to be paying the same
amount of tax because your house is
worth more
okay
um
it's okay if you don't know the answer
you can just say I'm not sure I'm
definitely not sure of specific numbers
that's for sure I was thinking through
though but thank you further questions
seeing on uh I want to thank you very
much also for testifying it's awesome to
see a young man with a family homeowner
and a landlord all at once that's
awesome welcome to New Hampshire uh next
all right still red
all right thank you chairman uh Alex
Madden from Derry uh speaking in support
of the bill
just come a little closer to the mic
thank you very good very good uh Alex
Madden from Derry speaking in support of
the bill
um I also am a young father
and it wanted to uh kind of address the
the greater context with within which
we're we're addressing this uh and and I
will get to the point very quickly but
um
you know the literally the entire
Western modernized world is is having
declining birth rates uh typically below
uh replacement even that's been the case
in the United States uh generally since
1971 specifically uh since 2007 uh and
and as has already been mentioned today
uh New Hampshire uh is is virtually
um the the second uh least in in that
category uh so so I think the context is
helpful because as the state
we are quite literally competing for
young people uh young people to provide
essential Services uh that that
everybody in our community needs this is
not just
um purely for young people with families
this is uh generally speaking going to
be a a benefit uh to the entire
Community
um my my journey down this road uh
started when I read a book by Peter
Francis who was an author he wrote about
the the demographic Trends in New
Hampshire he published a second book
about it and eventually he left for
Pennsylvania
to be with his family who would not
could not come back into the state they
didn't have the The Economic Opportunity
he I asked if I actually got in contact
with him asked him if he would give a
testimony he was unable to do so due to
a tooth infection but nonetheless he he
also expressed his uh his excuse me
I've I've known three families who have
left the state within the last year for
for greater
opportunities in in other states
um you know I I wouldn't say that a a
child tax credit would would uh have
single-handedly solved the problem for
those specific families but I think it
would be a step in the right direction
and and so you know we're
we're attempting to incentivize
something that you know as a community
we want to see more of at least I think
some of us want to see more of it and
and so by giving the local
municipalities the option but not the
requirement each Community can decide
for themselves
so uh thank you I'll take any questions
thank you for your testimony do we have
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony and I would Echo the same
things we said for angel thank you for
being a homeowner and a father and
having a family thank you thank you
chairman thank you okay we have one more
last time for this hearing on hb94 and
the last pink card of the day nature I
will be very brief Mr chair thank you
nature Grace for the municipal
Association again we don't have a
position on this bill just to make sure
the committee is aware we did
um ask our Board of Directors for some
guidance because there are a number of
local option tax credits coming uh
before this committee and others this
year and we were instructed not to have
a position on those but to provide
information and um
and and any sort of technical issues we
identified
um so line six uh it one of the
line six has the the word percentage we
would ask that if the committee
considers uh passing this that they
adopt an amendment to delete the word
percentage and the reason for that is we
need a fixed dollar amount in order to
uh accurately determine what property
taxes everyone's going to be paying as
well as what the appropriate amount is
to raise for the municipality
percentage just doesn't work because
it's gonna it's gonna depend on the
valuation of each individual's home
and that's gonna that's gonna change
over time and it's going to depend on
who moves where so we'd essentially be
required municipalities to track all the
children in town and where they live and
what the valuations are and that's not
going to work well
um line seven we weren't exactly sure if
there was supposed to be a
um a determination about how long
someone resided in town
um before they qualified for the the tax
credit it sounded like from the
introduction that may be left up to the
municipality
as much as it chagrins me to say this
um sometimes it's good for
municipalities to have some solid
guidelines
um as to when things should be running
um
so if that's something the committee is
concerned about
um we're happy to work with you on that
and
um line 11
is relating to the uh persons who rent
property and residents who reside on
rental property we've seen this in a
couple different
um
local option tax credits this year we
don't currently have a system to refund
renters amounts that are paid by the
property owners it's our our system is
set up for
um those who have an interest in the
property to receive the refund or you
know to receive the credit or the
exemption so this would be a new
system we're setting up so we want to
make you aware of that
um there may be questions that arise in
response to that as how exactly
municipalities ought to operate that
um and that leads me to my last Point
um which you've heard from Catherine in
assessing bills which is there's no
fractional interest Clause here so if
that was something that was of interest
to the municipality
um sorry the committee it's been a long
day we wanted to raise that so that no
clarification Bill had to come back in
Future years if this was something you
were interested in
and that's all I have unless the
committee has any questions for me thank
you
thank you for your testimony uh
uh representative Guthrie
thank you for
eign
thank you for the question I just have a
quick question because it's not clear on
my mind
who if we pass this bill who would set
up the parameters
or are they already set up in this CRS
rsas so it would apparently be part of
the local adoption it is different than
current systems so for example under the
elderly
um tax credit municipalities have the
option of giving a certain amount this
would appear to allow them to
according to what the sponsor or
co-sponsor said to Define that a little
a little bit more granually than
Mr chairman you got just a quick while
it wasn't clear to me
but who's going to do that the response
he has once he has the bill it's the
bill is ours it's not his who's going to
set up the parameters
is it this committee or is it
municipality once it goes through or if
you pass it as is presumably
the municipality is part of its warn
article could help Define who would
qualify
but it may be the case that this
committee
would like to set up parameters as part
of that state law in order to make sure
that municipalities are dealing what the
state policy would be as set by the
legislature I appreciate that thank you
thank you Mr chairman
representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so if this bill were
to become law and immune system and a
municipality were to adopt this
I would then assume is it is it correct
that the municipality would then set up
um an application form or system by
which a family would apply for this and
how is that information verified and
again who is going to set up that system
and in order to apply and verify the
information and and what would that take
in terms of man hours and administration
um
so I wouldn't
I wouldn't be able to provide an
estimate of how many man hours
Administration obviously any
municipality that shows any kind of
local option tax credit whether this one
or another one would have to administer
that local level there would be some
sort of administrative cost associated
with that presumably run run through the
local local assessor or contract
assessor depending on who the who the
representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Grace for taking my question
um if if this bill would have passed in
in some form you just said something
about fractional interests would I we
would I have to go back and amend my
beautiful Bill 197 to include the
language in here or are we running a
foul if if that doesn't happen with my
so I would like to keep my answer
relevant to this bill uh representative
it's a serious question to yell at me
otherwise
and Nate you are correct we are speaking
about this bill and representative
majority and uh and so I just mentioned
fractional interest because it's
possible
so I guess a scenario I would give you
is you have you know two parents they're
divorced one lives in the house but
they're both their names are on the deed
presumably the intent here would be to
give the parent who actually has custody
of the child the majority of the the tax
credit
um at least that's my assumption and the
other one may not live in that property
so that's what I meant by fractional
interest it's also possible you know
like
you have a multi uh family situation
where someone's parents assist them to
buy a property and their names are on
the deed and Etc so it could get
complicated
representative freeze
thank you Mr chairman um
and thank you for taking my question is
there a possibility that this would be
abused by the landlords
by turning over their attendance prefer
not to speculate as to what anyone may
do with any monies they receive
representative Stevens
Mr chair and thank you Mr Graves for
taking my question
the previous not the previous but
previous to the previous question raised
a question in my mind about joint
custody
would it be possible under the bill as
it's now written for both parents to
claim the tax credit if they had joint
custody
um I think that goes back to the
definition of of reside
um
and
I don't know what that definition is I
know the election law committee has been
struggling with that for years and I
would prefer not to get involved in that
debate
very good answer representative
mangaputi
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr Grace uh
for taking my question I will try
with this tax credit going to the
landlords it's great when a young family
with children are the landlords and it
helps them
if the young family is the renter with
Children what guarantee is there that
the renter the landlord pass on the
savings
would prohibit the landlord from keeping
so I think you raise an important point
to the committee for the committee to
consider which is
if it desires to pass this and create a
system whereby someone who's renting a
property could qualify for the credit
there probably needs to be Clarity on
line 11 for exactly how a municipality
is to administer that whether they're
supposed to give preference to the
renter or whether they give it to the
landlord who can claim it and how that
process works otherwise we may end up in
and with that thank you
it's the end of our hearing on the blue
sheet we have one two three four five
for the bill and we have one against
and with that we'll close the hearing on
hb294
so next week for our committee we will
be meeting back here Wednesday at 10 A.M
I believe we have eight or nine more
bills uh that we will go through on
hearings the following day we have a
house session I think most of you know
that
um after next Wednesday we are really
doing well we will only have I think six
or seven bills to go so we are well
ahead of schedule we're doing well
um the following week after
the house session next week we will be
obviously uh probably meeting twice
again we'll have a day of exacting and
probably take up our our final bills
um a couple Mr chairman
yes representative will we be executing
the bills that we heard a week ago
next week
um as of right now there are no bills
scheduled to be exact but there will be
some that we will exec in two weeks I
can't tell you exactly which ones right
now I haven't okay okay looked at them
um the other thing I briefly mentioned
it during our hearing if we could please
um when we have questions for the for
the individual testifying if we could
have him concise and to the point and be
truly questions rather than a long
lead-in of statement that would be very
very helpful
also the other thing that I wrote down
was about follow-ons follow-ons are
meant to be that follow-up follow-ups on
your initial question which the question
initial question should be to the
individual's testimony so let's make
sure
the follow-on is actually a follow-on
and here's the reason what I like to do
I don't know if you've noticed but I go
from side to side all right I want a
Democrat a Democrat Republican I try to
be as good as I can on that
I I don't want certain individuals
monopolizing the time because I also
want everybody involved with the
questioning okay so if you can keep your
true follow-ups to a follow-up on a
question you ask that's great otherwise
I will go to the next individual and
then once everybody's had a chance to
speak
then I will go back to the original
person who wants to ask an additional
question
was I clear
I see some furred eyebrows coming from
no good
well it looked like you were kind of
squinting okay
all right any further questions
as I said you speak very
infrequently so I gave you latitude
okay and with that we're done for the